ओके
सो आई थिंक आई एम लाइव नाउ गाइस लेट मी
चेक वंस एक बार मैं चेक कर लेता हूं जस्ट
वेट जस्ट वेट जस्ट वेट जस्ट वेट
गा जस्ट वेट कीजिए आप लोग एक बार चेक कर
लेता हूं यहां
पे हां
जी तो हम लाइव है राइट
ऑडियो विजुअल सब कुछ सही है गाइस प्लीज
लेट मी नो प्लीज लेट मी नो आवाज जा रही है
सबको क्लियर बिल्कुल क्लियर आवाज आ रही है
सबको प्लीज एक बार बता दीजिए लाउड एंड
क्लियर है ना
ऑडियो ठीक है ओके ठीक है ठीक है ठीक है
ठीक है इट्स क्लियर ओके
गुड ठीक है लाउड है बहुत लोग बोलते हैं कि
आवाज कम जा रही है आवाज कम रह रही है तो
ऐसे कुछ कम तो नहीं है ना एक बार बता
दीजिए एक बार प्लीज मैं यहां पे इसको सेट
अप कर देता हूं एक बार बता दीजिए प्लीज
ऐसे कोई कुछ कम तो नहीं
है हां क्लियर है ना ठीक है तो सभी लोगों
को आ जाने देते हैं जल्दी से सभी को जवाइन
करने देते हैं फटाफट एंड देन स्टार्ट करते
हैं आज की क्लास आज की क्लास बहुत शानदार
होने वाली है बहुत मजा आने वाला है आपको
बहुत कुछ सीखने को जानने को मिलने वाला है
हालांकि हर एक क्लास में मिल आपको जानने
सीखने को मिलता है बट आज की क्लास में और
भी इंटरेस्टिंग चीजें हैं जो आपको जाननी
है ठीक है और आपके कहने पे ये क्लास मैं
लेकर आया हूं ठीक है आपके कहने पे लेकर
आया हूं यह बात आपको ध्यान रखना है तो
आपको भी थोड़ी सी जो है ना उत्सुकता थोड़ी
सी एक्साइटमेंट दिखानी है आपको क्लास के
लिए आपने बोला था रेट लिमिट बायपास पे
हालांकि मैं वो वीडियो नहीं लेकर आने वाला
था मैं आपको कंसेप्ट सिखाने पे मेजर फोकस
करता हूं मेजर कि हां भाई एक आपको एक
रास्ता दिखाया जाए एंड उस रास्ते को पकड़
के आप आगे चल के और आपको वो चीजें नॉलेज
हो वो एक्चुअल स्किल आपकी गेन हो ठीक है
बट स्टिल आपने कहा तो मैं यहां पर लेकर
आपके लिए आ चुका हूं ठीक है गुड इवनिंग
एवरीबॉडी
तो नहीं ला सकता लेकिन हां ठीक है वी विल
ट्राई वी विल ट्राई टू ब्रिंग अ लॉट ऑफ
थिंग्स अ लॉट ऑफ थिंग्स सर यट टू कम ठीक
है काफी चीजें अभी बची हुई है अभी
तोलानी ओके चलिए तो मुझे यह बताइए आप में
से कितने लोगों ने नो रेट लिमिट का पार्ट
वन यानी कि इसके पहले की क्लास कंप्लीट
देखी एंड कर ली है कितने लोगों ने बता
दीजिए कितने लोग हैं आप में
से
बताइए मुझे बता दीजिए जरा मैं भी देखना
चाहता हूं
ठीक
है
ओके मिस हो गया था ठीक है कोई बात नहीं
कोई बात नहीं चलिए आज का जो सेशन है उसको
थोड़ा सा ध्यान दीजिएगा थोड़ा अच्छे से
इसको समझिए क्योंकि आज की जो सेशन है ना
वो थोड़ी सी प्रैक्टिकल अप्रोच थोड़ा
ज्यादा होगा इसमें एंड आपको रियल टारगेट्स
पे हम काम करने वाले हैं तो क्या है नो
रेट
लिमिट का ये क्लास पार्ट टू है जिसका नाम
है रेट लिमिट
बायपास टेक्निक्स तो रेट लिमिट के बायपास
टेक्निक्स को हम समझने वाले हैं इन सिंपल
शॉर्ट फॉर्म क्या है रेट लिमिट के बायपास
टेक्निक को हम सीखने वाले हैं जानने वाले
हैं अब देखो क्या होता है मैं आपको एक की
कांसेप्ट समझा देता हूं अभी जितने भी वेब
एप्लीकेशंस हैं जो मेजर वेब एप्लीकेशंस है
बड़ी कंपनीज हैं जिनके बग बाउंट
प्रोग्राम्स चल रहे होते हैं दे ऑलरेडी
हैव अप्लाइड वेरियस काइंड ऑफ रेट लिमिट
फंक्शनैलिटीज उस रेट लिमिट फंक्शनालिस को
अप्लाई करने के कारण सिक्योरिटी एक
मैकेनिज्म है रेट लिमिट उसके कारण क्या हो
सता है कि आप इन कंपनीज के ऊपर नो रेट
लिमिट लेबिलिटी जल्दी फाइंड नहीं कर
पाएंगे ठीक है यह बहुत ही बड़ा एक रीजन है
एंड यूजुअली बहुत सारी कंपनीज रेट लिमिट
जो वलने बिलिटी है नो रेट लिमिट की वह कुछ
कुछ पर्टिकुलर एक एंटिटी कुछ कुछ
पर्टिकुलर पॉइंट्स पर क्या करती है उसको
एक्सेप्ट नहीं करती है उनको क्या कर देती
हैं उनको वह रिजेक्ट करके रखती हैं इन द
सेंस कि वह आउट ऑफ स्कोप उनको बोल देती
हैं बट अगर किसी कंपनी में कोई सिक्योरिटी
लगी है लेट्स सपोज जस्ट फॉर एग्जांपल जस्ट
इमेज
ठीक है बहुत बढ़िया बहुत बढ़िया बहुत
बढ़िया अमनराज पांडे जस्ट फॉर एग्जांपल
जस्ट लेट्स सपोज कि अगर कोई कंपनी में
किसी भी तरह की सिक्योरिटी इंप्लीमेंटेड
है और अगर आप उसको बाईपास कर पाते हैं फॉर
एनी रीजन फर एनीवे तो वह एक वैलिड वनबिल
या वैलिड बग के केस में आएगा या नहीं आएगा
यह बताइए मुझे क्या लगता है आपको अगर आप
बायपास किसी भी तरह की सिक्योरिटी को
कंपनी के बायपास कर देते हैं आएगा
एक वैलिड बग की तरह कंसीडर किया जाएगा
कंपनी उसको एक्सेप्ट करेगी लगता है
ना बताइए सभी लोग बताइए प्लीज जितने
ज्यादा लोग रिप्लाई करेंगे रिस्पांस देते
हैं मुझे उतना ही मजा आता है और उतना ही
इंगेजिंग लगता है क्लास और उतना ही ज्यादा
मजा आता है आपको पढ़ाने में सिखाने में
ठीक है बस ट्स
इट
बताइए ठीक है बढ़िया एक रिक्वेस्ट यह भी
है कि आप सब लोग रिप्लाई की कीजिए जितने
भी लोग यहां पे हैं ना उतने लोग रिप्लाई
कीजिए क्योंकि आपके आपको यहां पे फ्री में
इतनी क्वालिटी ट्रेनिंग जो मैं दे रहा हूं
ना ये बहुत ज्यादा जगह आपको नहीं मिलने
वाली है कुछ लोग बोलते हैं कि अरे भाई
आपको सब्सक्राइबर्स मिल रहे हैं व्यूज मिल
रहे हैं इसलिए आप ट्रेनिंग दे रहे हो तो
भाई अगर ऐसी बात है कि मैं सब्सक्राइबर
अच्छी एकदम सही बात है बिल्कुल सही है कि
सब्सक्राइबर गेन हो रहे हैं व्यूज मिल रहे
हैं पॉपुलर हो रहा है चैनल बिल्कुल करेक्ट
है लेकिन सिर्फ इसके लिए अगर मैं आपको
ट्रेनिंग दे रहा हूं यह बात गलत है
क्योंकि अगर ऐसा है तो भाई साइबर
सिक्योरिटी के अंदर बहुत लोग हैं स्टार्ट
कर सकते हैं सीरीज सेम मेरी तरीके से
व्यूज और सब्सक्राइबर के लिए बट नहीं करते
हैं क्योंकि कर नहीं पाएंगे इतना आसान
नहीं है इतनी अंदर घुस के क्वालिटी पढाई
और एकदम फ्री में देने का ठीक है तो ये
बात पे मैं ज्यादा नहीं जाऊंगा बस इतना ही
बोलूंगा कि जो कुछ भी आपको करा रहा हूं वो
एकदम ऑनेस्टली और बहुत ही ज्यादा डीप जाके
कराने की कोशिश कर रहा हूं ठीक है एक
इंटरमीडिएट लेवल तक तो आपको करा दे रहा
हूं कई सारी केसेस में तो आप बहुत ही ऊपर
लेवल टॉप लेवल पर चले जा रहे हैं थोड़ा
एक्सप्लोर खुद से करेंगे तो आप वहां पर
प्रो बन जाएंगे प्रो बनना आपके हाथ में है
मेरे हाथ में नहीं है प्रो कोई भी मेंटर
कोई भी टीचर आपको नहीं बनाता टीचर आपको
गाइड करेगा आपको अच्छे रिसोर्सेस देगा
अच्छे तरीके से आपको पढ़ाए सिखाएगा प्रो
बनना आपके हाथ में है ठीक है ना कोई वो
आपके एक्सप्लोर करने की क्या क्षमता है
कितना आप कर पा रहे हैं टाइम दे पा रहे
हैं सब उस परे डिपेंड करता है ठीक है
ओके
चलिए बिल्कुल बिल्कुल धन्यवाद धन्यवाद
धन्यवाद भाई तो चलिए यहां पे रेट लिमिट
बायपास टेक्निक्स को हम पढ़ने वाले हैं
एंड यहां पे आज काफी लोग आ चुके हैं 62
लोग बढ़िया है 100 की एक्सपेक्टेशन हम
रखते हैं बट स्टिल नहीं है कोई बात नहीं
को चलेगा कोई दिक्कत नहीं इसके पहले एक
चीज बता देता हूं हर एक वीडियो के
डिस्क्रिप्शन में आप लाइव के जाइएगा तो
हमारा
पेज जो आपको पता ही है मैं आपको हर वीडियो
में बताता हूं हमारी कंपनी का जो लिंकडन
पेज है डिफ्रॉक साइबर सिक्योरिटी इसको आप
फॉलो कर लीजिएगा जो भी अपडेट्स जो भी सारी
कंपनी से रिलेटेड जो भी चीजें अपडेट्स हैं
वो आपको यहीं पे मिल जाएंगी ठीक है चलिए
तो गाइस अब आज जो हम पढ़ने वाले हैं रेट
लिमिट बायपास टेक्निक्स तो कंपनीज में रेट
लिमिट जो है ना वो लगाई गई रहती है रेट
लिमिट अब रेट लिमिट को अगर आपने बायपास कर
दिया तो उस वनबिल को उस पर्टिकुलर बग को
110 पर
एक्सेप्ट एक्सेप्ट किया जाएगा किसी भी
कंपनी के तरफ से ठीक है देखते हैं ललित
देखते हैं देखते हैं किसी भी तरीके से
एक्सेप्ट किया जाएगा बट अब वही बात है रेट
लिमिट बायपास हम कैसे करें पहले आप यह समझ
पा रहे हो कि रेट लिमिट क्या होता है यह
मैंने पहले क्लास में बताया था देखो सिंपल
सा फंडा है रेट लिमिट का मैं आपको बहुत ही
क्लियर
कंसाइनर के तरफ एक सिक्योरिटी मैकेनिज्म
लगी होती है कि उस सर्वर पर कोई भी यूजर
या कोई भी क्लाइंट अनलिमिटेड रिक्वेस्ट ना
कर पाए बेकार की रिक्वेस्ट की लाइन ना लगा
पाए ताकि सर्वर पर लोड ना बढ़े सर्वर अपनी
सर्विसेस प्रॉपर्ली यूजर्स को दे पाए एंड
इस वजह से रेट लिमिट लगाई जाती है फॉर
सिक्योरिटी रीजन अब इसी रेट लिमिट को अगर
कोई
अटैकर बायपास कर देता है तो वह सर्वर पर
अनइंटेंशनली या इंटेंशनली कुछ भी बहुत
सारे रिक्वेस्ट एक बार में भेज सकता है
जिसके कारण कई ऑथेंटिकेशन प्रॉब्लम्स
इश्यूज आ सकते हैं ऑथेंटिकेशन के
रिगार्डिंग डीडीओएस जैसे अटैक्स हो सकते
हैं उस पर्टिकुलर सर्वर के ऊपर में उस
पर्टिकुलर सर्वर जो पर्टिकुलर सर्वर है
अपनी सर्विसेस देना बंद कर सकता है
लीकेजेस बहुत सारी चीजें हो सकती है उस
सर्वर के साइट से बहुत सारी प्रॉब्लम्स हो
सकती है एंड यह जो वने बिलिटी है यह
एक्चुअल बहुत ही सीवियर वने बिलिटी है अगर
हम बायपास कर पाते हैं तो चलिए मैं अब
आपको दिखाता
हूं ठीक है चलिए मैं अब आपको यह चीज एक
बार दिखा देता हूं एक बार पहले चीज समझाता
हूं फिर आगे लेकर चलते हैं अब जैसे कि मैं
इसके लिए मैं अपना क्या
करूंगा ट का क्या करना है
भैया
एक्सेस क्या हुआ है बंद हो गया है क्या
बंद हो गया है समझा नहीं मैं का तो एक्सेस
चालू है यार पर आप मैसेज कर सकते हो कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है पर मैसेज करने का एक्सेस
ऑलरेडी स्टार्ट है कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है
देख सकते हो
आप चलो ठीक है अब मैं आपको यहां पर दिखाता
हूं बट उसको दिखाऊंगा कैसे मैं आपको
स्क्रीन शेयर भी करूंगा और वह भी दिखाऊंगा
सब चीज दिखाऊंगा ठीक है
चलिए नहीं नहीं अभी मैसेजिंग चालू है
एडमिन ओनली नहीं है मैसेजिंग चालू है
अभी मैसेजिंग
whatsapp's ओपन firefox.exe
[संगीत]
बाउंट सिलेक्ट कर लेते
हैं य आते
हैं ठीक है यहां पे
ओपन ओपन बग बाउंट यहां करते हैं ब्राउज बग
बांटी प्रोग्राम्स य बग बाउटी प्रोग्राम्स
को ब्राउज करते इसके
सॉरी ठीक है यहां पर बग बाउटी प्रोग्राम्स
आ गए ओपन बग बाउटी के यहां पर कोई सा भी
एक प्रोग्राम चूज कर लेते हैं
लाइक चलिए यह प्रोग्राम है यह यह
प्रोग्राम है जिसमें ठीक है यह स्टेट है
इसके चलो u.com इसको चूज कर लिया हमने
u.com की सारी डोमस सारी सब डोमेन जो है
इंक्लूडेड है इसके स्कोप में तो लेट्स ओपन
दिस
डोमेन ओके लेट्स ओपन इट चलिए हमने ओपन कर
दिया यहां पर ये चीज ओपन हो गई है यह
पर्टिकुलर डोमेन अब यहां पे हम हमें देखना
है कि हम यहां पर नो मतलब नो रेट लिमिट
लेबिलिटी कुछ फाइंड कर पाएंगे या नहीं कर
पा रहे हैं या नहीं कर पा रहे हैं यह हमें
देखना है राइट तो हमें यहां पे देखना है
कहीं लॉगिन साइन अप पेज वगैरह है नहीं है
यहां पे लॉगइन साइन अप पेज कहीं लॉगइन
साइन अप पेज नहीं है
अ माय एड्स पर चलते
हैं ठीक है माय एड्स प यहां पे साइन इन है
साइन इन बट ये
एंटर करने का चलिए यहां पर मैं करता हूं
टेंप मेल से एक ईमेल ले लेते हैं ठीक है
चलिए यहां पर ध्यान दीजिएगा सभी लोग प्लीज
एवरीवन प्लीज इधर ध्यान दीजिएगा मैं आपको
अभी रेट लिमिट को बायपास करने के तरीके
बताऊंगा ठीक है पूरा स्टार्टिंग से सब कुछ
बता रहा हूं बढ़िया तरीके से एक अरेंज वे
में ताकि आपको मजा आ जाए ठीक है
चलिए यहां से मैंने कॉपी
किया कॉपी किया यहां पे आ गए यहां हमने
हां जी ईमेल आईडी डाल दी ठीक है यहां हमने
सेंड किया सेंड करने पे क्या आ रहा है ये
सॉरी यू डोंट हैव एनी एक्टिव एड्स प्लीज
ऐड प्ली प्लेस एन ऐड नाउ अच्छा ठीक है ऐड
यहां पे ऐड करना पड़ेगा ठीक है कोई बात
नहीं यहां पे पोस्ट फ्री ऐड पे चलते हैं
यहां पे पोस्ट फ्री ऐड पे आने पे यहां पे
हम ऐड पोस्ट करेंगे एंड यहां पे हमसे ईमेल
आईडी मांग रहा है ठीक है इट्स आस्किंग
ईमेल आईडी फ्रॉम अस हियर तो हम यहां पे एक
टाइटल ऐड कर देते हैं ऐड के लिए तो ऐड कर
देते हैं डे डेफ ड फोनिक्स ड की कैटेगरी
चूज कर लेते हैं हाउसेस कुछ भी कर लो ड
टेक्स्ट
हेलो पोस्ट दिस ड प्लीज दिस ड इज
रिगार्डिंग
टेस्टिंग ऑफ अ
बग कुछ भी डाल दो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है ठीक
है यहां पर ये कर लिया उसके बाद यहां पे
प्राइस डाल देते कुछ भी टूथ 4 कुछ भी डाल
कोई दिक्कत नहीं इमेज ब्राउज करके डालने
का आ रहा है इमेज करना है तो करो या कोई
बात नहीं ईमेल आईडी डालने को बोल रहा है
तो ईमेल आईडी मैं यहां पे मेरी वाली ईमेल
आईडी डाल देता हूं
नितेश
हैकर
gmail.com ठीक है तो हमने ये ईमेल आईडी
डाल दी नितेश singh@gmail.com ठीक है चलिए
हमने ये वाली ईमेल आईडी भी डाल दिया तो अब
हम यहां पे पोस्ट माय ऐड करेंगे बट पोस्ट
माय ऐड करने से पहले हम इस रिक्वेस्ट को
एक बार कैप्चर करेंगे और देखेंगे रेट
लिमिट के लिए ठीक है तो मैं यहां पे क्या
कर करता हूं इस ईमेल आईडी पे मेल आएगी तो
कहां दिखाऊंगा मैं आपको आपको स्क्रीन पर
दिखाऊंगा तो चलिए मैं आपको स्क्रीन पर
दिखाता हूं जस्ट
वेट जस्ट वेट मैं स्क्रीन शेयर कर लेता
हूं यहां पे फोन की हेयर इट
इज यह
रही फोन ऑन पीसी मिरर कर लेते
हैं ठीक है यहां पे स्टार्ट कर देते हैं
स्टार्ट पीसी चलिए देखते
हैं हां जी तो यहां पर आ चुका है हमारा
फोन ओके यहां पर हमारा फोन आ चुका है नाउ
ल आई एम ओपनिंग द ईमेल जो मेल आईडी है व
ओपन कर लेता हूं जो मैं यहां पर दूंगा ओके
यह कौन सी मेल है मेटसन ठीक है मेटन वाली
मेल आईडी है चलो यही वाली मेल आईडी दे
देते हैं मेन वाली दे देते हैं कोई दिक्कत
नहीं ठीक है तो यहां पे हम एक मेल आईडी
यूज कर रहे हैं दैट इज मे सलूशन
मेव
सलूशन
gmail.com gmail.com यहां पर हमने वो कर
लिया gmail.com ठीक है है चलिए हो गया अब
यहां प पोस्ट में ऐड करने से पहले हम इसको
इसके रिक्वेस्ट को कैप्चर करेंगे तो उसके
लिए हम बॉब शूट को ओपन कर लेते एक बार
लेट्स स्टार्ट बॉब
शूट लेट्स रन
इट चलिए बप शूट को स्टार्ट करते हैं फाइल
फाइल अपलोड नहीं हो रही य फाइल अपलोड
लेबिलिटी नहीं पढ़ रहे हम दूसरी वने
एबिलिटी पढ़ रहे हैं एक बार टाइटल देखो आप
आज की क्लास
की ठीक है यहां पे प्रॉक्सी पे इंटरसेप्ट
ऑफ कर लेते हैं एंड गो हियर यहां से हम
अपनी बब बब शूट की प्रॉक्सी इनेबल कर देते
हैं ब्राउजर से ठीक है दैट्ची
रिक्वेस्ट को राइट क्लिक करेंगे सेंड टू
इंट्रूडर भेजते हैं इंट्रूडर को भी भेज
देते हैं सेंड टू सीक्वेंस भी भेज देते
हैं दोनों को भेज देते हैं इंटरसेप्ट को
यहां पे हम ऑफ करेंगे ऑफ करने के पहले मेल
आईडी मैं ओपन कर लेता हूं अपना एंड देखता
हूं कि यहां पे मेल आता है कि नहीं
इंटरसेप्टर को ऑफ किया एंड लेट्स सी द मेल
तो यहां पे कंफर्म योर न्यू ऑर्डर अ न्यू
ऐड डेफ ऐड यहां पे आ चुका है यहां पे डेफ
ऐड ठीक है तो यहां पे हमें एक मेल आई है
प्लीज क्लिक हियर अ क्लिक ऑन द लिंक बिलो
टू कंफर्म योर न्यू क्लासिफाइड ऐड ठीक है
तो यहां पे हमें एक मतलब मेल आई है यहां
पे ठीक है क्लासिफाइड ड ऐड करने का यहां
पे मेल आया हुआ है ठीक है राइट दो बार
यहां पर हमें मेल आए हुए हैं बढ़िया दो
मेल आए हुए हैं अभी तक यह आपको दिख रहा है
सबको मेल दो बार आई हुई है इसकी मेल
करेंटली एवरीवन कैन सी प्लीज लेट मी नो
स्क्रीन दिख रही है आपको मोबाइल की जो
मैंने मेल आईडी ओपन की है मेक्स सलूशन जो
हमने डाला हुआ
था एवरीवन कैन सी प्लीज लेट मी
नो दिख रहा है कि नहीं दिख रहा है या छोटा
कैसे या सही है क्योंकि इतनी बड़ी स्क्रीन
हो पाएगी इससे ज्यादा बड़ी नहीं हो पाएगी
दिख रहा है चलिए तो अब हम यहां पे चलते
हैं सीक्वेंसर पे सीक्वेंसर पे हम जब चलते
हैं तो यहां पे ये आ चुकी है हमारे
सीक्वेंसर के अंदर में एंड यहां पे हमें
फॉर्म फील्ड का एक मिल चुका है ऐड इज
इक्वल टू ऐड करके एक फॉर्म फील्ड मिल चुकी
है कुकी नहीं मिली है बट फॉर्म फीड मिल
चुका है कोई भी या इसमें से कोई भी कुकी
मिल जाए या फॉर्म फीड मिल जाए या कस्टम
लोकेशन भी आप डाल के सीक्वेंसर चला सकते
हो अगर सक्सेसफुल होगा तो यह काम करेगा
कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है ठीक है तो हम यहां
पे स्टार्ट लाइव कैप्चर पे क्लिक करते हैं
लेट्स सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग ठीक है तो हमने
स्टार्ट लाइव कैप्चर किया एंड हम फोन पर आ
जाते हैं लेट्स सी फोन पर देखते हैं कि
मेल्स आते हैं और या
नहीं चार मेल छ मेल आए हैं अभी सात मेल आए
हैं आठ मेल आए हैं यह देख सकते हो तुम आठ
मेल आ गए हैं यहां पे यहां पर देख सकते
हो चलो 13 मेल आए हैं 14 मेल आए हैं सॉरी
सॉरी यह मेल क्यू मैंने बंद कर दिया यहां
से हां यह रहा मैं यहां पर रिफ्रेश भी कर
देता हूं 22 मेल आए हैं 24 मेल आए अभी तक
26 मेल आए है सीक्वेंसर अभी भी हमारा चल
रहा है यहां पर आप देख सकते हो यहां पर 30
मेल आ चुके हैं मुझे मुझे नहीं लगता इसमें
रेट लिमिट है चलो 34 आ चुके मेल 36 आ चुके
हैं देखते हैं लेट्स सी लेट्स सी कभी कभी
50 के बाद स्टॉप हो जाएंगे आपके अगर
कभी-कभी 50 का या 100 का भी होता है रेट
लिमिट तो अभी देखते हैं 44 आ चुके हैं
46 40 50 मेल आ चुके हैं गाइस 52 मेल आ
चुके
हैं 52 54 मेल आ चुके हैं दिस इज नो रेट
लिमिट 5960 कोई रेट लिमिट नहीं लगी है यह
अभी तक तो मुझे यही लग रहा है
अ
61 यह देखिए आप
लोग यह
74 हां 78 100 तक हम देखते हैं 100 कई बार
100 रिक्वेस्ट का लगा रहता है आपका लिमिट
तो एक बार 100 का देख लेते हैं 84 अभी आ
रहा है यह 88 हो चुका
है लास्ट में पूछ लेना ज्ञानेश लास्ट में
बिल्कुल
95 क्या लग रहा है 100 से ऊपर जाएगा क्या
बताओ
जल्दी
100 100 के बाद दूसरी चैट शुरू हो जाएगी
यह देखो दूसरी चैट शुरू हो चुकी है दूसरी
चैट शुरू हो चुकी है गाइस एंड यह भी चैट
भी आ रही है मतलब इसमें भी आ रहा है वाओ
ग्रेट तो यहां पे 12 14 हो गए इसमें भी 14
यानी कि 100 वाली रेट लिमिट तो नहीं है
भाई ठीक है और कितनी क्लासेस है बहुत सारी
क्लासेस है अभी 100
प्लस अ
125 क्या बात है 125 128 मेल आप देख रहे
हो यहां पे पता है क्या हो रहा है ये ये
रेट लिमिट तो बायपास मतलब बायपास रेट
लिमिट नहीं है ये मतलब नो रेट लिमिट यहां
पे वलने बिलिटी है रेट लिमिट नहीं लगी है
लेकिन यह उनके रिसोर्स को एग्जॉस्ट कर रहा
है रिसोर्स को एग्जॉस्ट कर रहा है अगर कोई
भी सर्विस किसी पर्टिकुलर सर्वर ने ली है
ना किसी कंपनी ने ली है मान लो कहीं कोई
एपीआई परचेस किया है या एपीआई यूज केस यूज
कर रहे हैं एंड किसी एपीआई का यूज़ करके
कोई इंफॉर्मेशन फेच कर रहे हैं एपीआई की
लिमिट होती है कि भैया इतने रिक्वेस्ट पर
मिनट इतने रिक्वेस्ट पर सेकंड अगर वो कर
रखा है और हम यहां पे अगर उसको पूरी की
पूरी एग्जॉस्ट कर देंगे तो बाद में वो
पर्टिकुलर एपीआई का यूज करके वो ओटीपी
नहीं सेंड कर पाएगा पर्टिकुलर कंपनी तो एक
तरह का क्या हो जाता है वो दूसरे यूजर्स
के लिए वो प्रॉब्लम हो गया फॉर अदर यूजर्स
दैट विल बी अ कंप्लीट प्रॉब्लम दैट विल बी
अ कंप्लीट प्रॉब्लम तो अभी 175 हो गया अब
ये
बताओ 80 हो
गए धन्यवाद राहुल शौ 86 हो गए हां डी हां
एक तरह का वही हुआ ना सर्विस जब कोई भी
कोई भी सर्विस वो ना हो तो वही हो गया एक
तरह से डस हो गई एक तरह कोई भी सविस कोई स
देखते 200 के पार करता है कि नहीं 200 के
पार होगा क्या यह यह
बताना हे भगवान कोई लिमिट ही नहीं है मतलब
कुछ नहीं है गाइस व आर जस्ट एस्टिंग देर
रिसोर्सेस जस्ट एस्टिंग एवरीथिंग मतलब हम
एग्जॉस्ट कर रहे हैं कुछ है ही नहीं यह
कुछ है ही नहीं मतलब आप देख सकते हो इस
पर्टिकुलर अगर हम इस पर्टिकुलर वेबसाइट की
बात करें मैं इसको यहां पे सिंपल रीलोड
करता हूं यहां पे मैं यहां पे चलो रिसेंड
क्या करता हूं मैं इसको पोस्ट फ्री ऐड
वाले को ओपन करता हूं यहां पे बस यह सिंपल
आ गया लेकिन यहां पे यह चीज हो ही रही है
देखो यहां पे 234 हो गए 234 हो गए मतलब
कोई रेट लिमिट नहीं जब इतने रिक्वेस्ट आके
और इतनी चीजें हो जाए तो आप समझ लो कि
यहां रेट लिमिट का कुछ है ही नहीं सीन ही
नहीं है कोई रेट लिमिट का ठीक है अबकी बार
400 पा
बिल्कुल बिल्कुल अगर देखो
अच्छा मेलिंग जो होती है उसके लिए हमें
एसएमटीपी सर्वर सेटअप करना पड़ता है
एसएमटीपी कंफिल करनी पड़ती है अगर आप
बार-बार कोई रिसोर्सेस एग्जॉस्ट करोगे
बार-बार कोई रिक्वेस्ट अगर सोचो ना किसी
भी सर्वर पे चाहे व एसएमटीपी हो या कोई सी
भी सर्वर हो कोई सी भी सर्विस की सर्वर हो
जब आप उसपे एक बार बहुत सारे रिक्वेस्ट
भेजोगे तो ओबवियसली उसके रिसोर्सेस
एग्जॉस्ट होंगे एंड जब वो होंगे तो वो
अपनी सर्विस देना बंद कर देंगे यह कॉमन सा
कांसेप्ट है कॉमन सी चीज है ठीक है समझ
में आ रहा है सब लोगों
को समझ में आ रहा है यह नो रेट लिमिट है
यह सिंपल सा
फंडा नहीं इससे पर्टिकुलर इस चीज से ओनली
डाउन होने की संभावना बहुत कम है क्योंकि
हम एक ही अभी पर्टिकुलर आईपी से एक
रिक्वेस्ट का वो कर रहे हैं हां लेकिन अगर
यही चीज हम मल्टीपल आईपी से मल्टीपल
सिस्टम से अगर हम एक साथ करते हैं बहुत
सारे रिक्वेस्ट एक बार में जाते हैं तो
वहां पे डीडीओएस हो सकता है ठीक
है ठीक है समझ गया अब मैं इसको रोक देता
हूं मैं यहां पे स्टॉप कर देता हूं फिलहाल
के लिए ज्यादा हम नहीं करेंगे स्टॉप करने
के कुछ देर बाद तक ये मेल आएंगी देखना
मैंने स्टॉप कर दिया यहां पे मैं इसको
क्लोज भी कर देता हूं सीक्वेंसर को अभी भी
मेल आएंगे कुछ देर तक क्योंकि पहले जो
रिक्वेस्ट ऑलरेडी निकल चुकी है वो अपनी जो
चीजें हैं काम है वो करके ही रहेंगी तो
यहां पे कुछ देर तक ये चलता
रहेगा ये कुछ देर तक चलता रहेगा ठीक है ये
आप देख सकते हो इट इट्स स्टिल ऑन गोइंग 36
38 जो भी है ये चलता रहेगा ओके तो फिलहाल
के लिए मैं इसको डिलीट कर देता हूं यहां
पे जो बाकी तीन है इनको अरे
यार इनको मैं डिलीट कर देता हूं अब ये जो
आ रहे हैं इनको आने देते हैं कोई बात नहीं
ये हमारा भी तो मेल बॉक्स यार फिल हो रहा
है फालतू का ठीक है तो यहां पे ये चलते रह
रहे हैं कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है इट विल कीप
गोइंग राइट तो यहां पे इसको अभी हम फिलहाल
के लिए रहने देते हैं इसको हम फिलहाल के
लिए क्या कर देते हैं मिनिमाइज कर देते
हैं इसको हम इसको हम अभी के लिए यहां से
हटा देते हैं ठीक है तो ये तो एक
पर्टिकुलर वलन एबिलिटी हो गई ये तो एक चीज
हो गई अब इसी तरह से आप इंट्रूडर पे भी
जाके सेम चीज कर सकते हो पोजीशन पे जा
सकते हो यहां क्लियर कर सकते हो कोई भी एक
पोजीशन उठा लो और यहां पे नंबर्स चला दो
जो भी नंबर जो मैंने बताया हुआ ऑलरेडी वो
काम कर लो हो जाएगा आपका ठीक है चलिए तो
ये तो एक वल्नरेबल वेबसाइट थी अब ऐसी
वेबसाइट्स कहां-कहां होती है कहां-कहां
चीजें होती हैं कैसे बायपास की जाती है वह
मैं बताता हूं अब ऐसी वेबसाइट होंगी जहां
पर रेट लिमिट लेबिलिटी नहीं होंगी जहां पे
नहीं होंगी जैसे कि फॉर एग्जांपल चलिए अब
मैं यहां पे एक देख अब मैं यहां पर एक और
वेबसाइट लेकर चलता हूं कोई एक वेबसाइट
लेते हैं जैसे
कि बैक करते हैं कोई और वेबसाइट लेते
हैं sa.com ले लेते हैं देखते हैं
इंडियन वेबसाइट कोई नहीं है क्या इसमें जथ
नेट ले लेते हैं आई डोंट नो व्ट दिस डोमेन
इ बट ओबवियसली यहां से हमें थोड़ा इंडियन
वाला कोई वो लेते हैं एक बार ईमेल वाली तो
हम देख ही चुके हैं मैं ओटीपी का सोच रहा
था एक बार देख लेने का तो लेट्स
सी ब्रेव जी गेमिंग गाइस प्लीज स्टॉप
टॉकिंग
योरसेल्फ यहां पर यह कुछ भी नहीं है है
मतलब नॉट फॉर अस हां जी यहां पे साइन इन
का ऑप्शन आ रहा है साइन इन ठीक
है
ओके
अ ठीक है आई थिंक यह बाहर की है कंपनी है
कोई तो चलिए यहां पे बाहर की कंपनी है कोई
यहां पे तो हम एक काम करते हैं इसी को हम
रखते हैं फिलहाल के लिए एंड लेट्स गो टू
साइन इन क्रिएट अकाउंट ठीक है क्रिएट
अकाउंट पे हम क्लिक कर देते हैं चलिए एक
हम क्रिएट अकाउंट पे चलते हैं यहां पे
ईमेल आईडी मांग रहा है कि भैया ईमेल आईडी
डालो यहां पे तो फिलहाल के लिए मैं एक
टेस्ट मेल डाल के चेक करता हूं कि या फिर
चलो अपना ही मेल आईडी डाल देते हैं ठीक है
तो मैं यहां पे मैं टैक्स वन सशन @
gmail.com ये डाल देते हैं ठीक है mx1 सशन
@
gmail.com इसको हम साइन इन पे क्लिक करते
हैं लेट्स सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग अगर इसको
मैं रिक्वेस्ट को कैप्चर करूंगा अगर कोई
ओटीपी भेजता है तो हमें वो होके मिल जाएगा
तो साइन इन पर क्लिक करते हैं लेट्स सी
व्ट इज हैपनिंग ओके देयर इज अ रीकैप्चर
एपीआई टू रीलोड एंड यहां पर री कैप्चा
फॉर्म एक आपके सामने आने वाला है यानी कि
कैप्चा आने वाला है ठीक है सिंपल सा यहां
पर क्या आने वाला है रीकैप्चा यहां पर आने
वाली है तो चलिए अब यहां पर देखते
हैं लेट्स
सी फच डेस्ट एमटी यहां पे एंड कुछ भी नहीं
है सेकच ठीक है ओके तो यहां पे हमें यह
रिक्वेस्ट आई है कोई बात नहीं यह
रिक्वेस्ट आई है रीलोड करके यहां पे
फॉरवर्ड करते
हैं चलिए फॉरवर्ड करते हैं फॉरवर्ड करते
हैं फॉरवर्ड करते हैं ओके v2 sa.com यहां
पे एपीआई पोस्ट ऑथेंटिकेट यहां पे आया हुआ
है यहां पे इनपुट में टक्सन सॉल्यूशन आई
है यहां पे एक टोकन जनरेट हो रही है आप
यहां पे देखिए यहां पे ठीक है एक टोकन
जनरेट हो रही है यहां पे यहां पे यूयू
आईडी यहां पे आपकी मिल रही है ईमेल
वेरिफिकेशन ट्रू आ रही है यहां पे ठीक है
अब हम यहां पे एक बार इसको देखेंगे इसको
को मैं क्या करता हूं राइट क्लिक करके
सेंड टू इंट्रूडर कर देता हूं सेंड टू
सीक्वेंसर कर देता हूं इस रिक्वेस्ट को
सेंड टू रिपीटर भी कर देता हूं मैं इसको
फॉरवर्ड करता हूं देखते हैं क्या होता है
अ फॉरवर्ड करते हैं फॉरवर्ड करते हैं
फॉरवर्ड करते हैं ओके फॉरवर्ड करते हैं
फॉरवर्ड करते हैं फॉरवर्ड कर देते हैं
फॉरवर्ड करते हैं फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड
फॉरवर्ड कोई चीज है उसका मैं रिस्पांस
देखना चाहिए था बट ठीक है कोई बात नहीं
इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ करके यहां पे देखते हैं
क्या होता है चलिए ओके यहां रीकैप्चा वाली
चीज है वही बात है कैप्चा वाली चीज
इन्होंने लगा रखी है तो हम यहां पे इसको
ओके कर देते हैं फायर हाइड्रस इसको हम
नेक्स्ट कर देते हैं बाइक को वेरीफाई कर
लेते हैं अरे भैया क्या दिक्कत
है चलिए तो क्रॉस
वॉक बाइसिकल
बस भाई बस क्या कर रहे हो ट्रैफिक लाइट्स
क्या बात
है इतना टाइम तो यार लगा ही नहीं था इतना
टाइम क्यों लग रहा है ये इसमें
यह लो बस यह लो बस यह लो बस बता रहे
हो सर अभी एक आई आईडीयो रिपोर्ट करके आ
रहा हूं थैंक यू सर आई एम ऑन क्लास 24
क्या बात है क्या बात है कांग्रेचुलेशन और
लिंकन पर भी डालो यार लिंकन पर डालो टैक
करो डि फोनिक साइबर सिक्योरिटी को तभी तो
मजे आएंगे चलिए यहां पर एक बस थी वेरीफाई
कर लेते हैं अब तो हो जाना चाहिए चलो ठीक
है तो यहां पे हो चुका है ईमेल आईडी हमने
डाल दिया है यहां पर हम कुछ नहीं करते
यहां पर फर्स्ट नेम डालते हैं ठीक है तो
फर्स्ट नेम में मैं डाल देता हूं राहुल
लास्ट नेम में डाल देता
हूं पारस ठीक है अभी भी मेल आ रहे व वाले
वो जो ईमेल वाली मेल थ अभी भी आ रहा है य
पासवर्ड डाल देता
हूं ओके ए यहां पर क्रिएट अकाउंट कर देते
हैं पासवर्ड जो है वह थोड़ी सी गड़बड़ है
ठीक
है चलिए फिर से कर देते हैं
स्पेशल कैरेक्टर होना चाहिए वन अपर कर
मिनिमम 12 कैरेक्टर
वाओ जीरो जीरो तक कर दिया हमने क्रिएट
अकाउंट कर लेते हैं य
पर लेट्स क्रिएट द अकाउंट अभी तक वह मेल आ
रही है आपको पता है ट मेल इज कमिंग स्टिल
चलिए तो हम यहां पर आ चुके हैं गाइस वी
हैव कम हियर वी हैव कम यर मैं आपको दिखाऊं
एक चीज वो मेल अभी तक आ रही है भाई अभी तक
यह देखो कुछ ज्यादा ही देर चला दी थी हमने
यह देखो कितनी बार आ चुकी है अभी एक दोती
च 400 बार तो वैसे आ गई है हमने डिलीट कर
दी थी व वाली मेल यह देखो 400 बार तो वैसे
आ चुकी है जबकि अटैक को रोक दिया है अटैक
चालू नहीं है गाइस अटैक हैज बीन स्टॉप्ड
यहां सीक्वेंसर प देखो चलो मैं इसको यहां
से रिमूव भी कर देता हूं यार यहां से हटा
भी देता हूं इंट्रूडर इंट्रूडर से भी हटा
ही दिया होगा शायद कौन सा ये डाबू हटाओ
यार हटाने से कुछ नहीं है ना अटैक ही नहीं
चल रहा हमारा अटैक ही नहीं काम कर रहा यार
तो फिर क्या मतलब है यह बिना मतलब का ये
ये पागल अभी भी पगलो जैसे आया जा रहा है
यार ये हटाओ इसको यार तंग आ गया मैं तो
हटाओ चलो हट गया
ये होप फुली अब ना आए अभी भी आ रहा है चलो
यार इसका कोई बात नहीं इसका हम देख लेंगे
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है अबकी बार 400 नहीं 600
पार हो ग ये तो चलिए अब यहां पे जब हम आ
चुके हैं गाइस तो यहां पे टू फैक्टर
ऑथेंटिकेशन की सेटिंग है और भी बहुत सारी
चीजें हैं यहां पे अब एक काम कर देते हैं
व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू डू लॉग इन
सिक्योरिटी पासवर्ड सिक्योरिटी आ रहा है
अपडेट पासवर्ड का आ रहा है अच्छी बात है
अब मैं क्या करता हूं ना यहां से लॉग आउट
हो जाता हूं पहले
तो आई एम गोइंग टू लॉग आउट ठीक है ल लॉग
आउट कर दिया अब यहां पे फॉरगेट ईमेल और
पासवर्ड आ रहा है तो फॉरगेट ईमेल पासवर्ड
वाले ऑप्शन पे चलते हैं यहां पे हम क्या
करते हैं इंटर यो डोमेन और ईमेल एड्रेस तो
यहां पे मैं ईमेल एड्रेस डाल देता हूं मैं
टक्स वन सल
gmail.com यह डाला अब यहां पर हम कंटिन्यू
करेंगे कंटिन्यू कंटिन्यू करते ही देखते
हैं क्या होता है लेट्स सी यहां पर एक मेल
आई है चेक योर मेल ठीक है यहां पर एक मेल
आई है एंड यह मेल हमें आई होगी इसके तरफ
से पासवर्ड रिसेट मेल देखो अभी आई है कि
नहीं आई है देखते
हैं कहां य पासवर्ड रिसेट मेल हा यह आया
एक पासवर्ड रिसेट मेल ठीक है भाई ये तुम
यार बंद हो जाओ भाई
ठीक है यहां पे आया पासवर्ड रिसेट मेल तो
हमें यहां पर पासवर्ड रिसेट मेल यहां पे आ
चुका है अच्छी बात है अब एक काम करते हैं
यहां पे अब एक काम करते हैं बैक करते हैं
क्लोज करते हैं इसको साइन इन प चलते हैं
साइन इन प चलते हैं यहां
पे फॉरगेट योर ईमेल और पासवर्ड प आ जाते
हैं यहां पे हम अपना मेल आईडी डाल देते
हैं
मव सलूशन @ gmail.com एंड इस रिक्वेस्ट को
कैप्चर कर लेते हैं एक बार प्रॉक्सी प
चलते हैं इंटरसेप्ट ऑफ और इंटरसेप्ट ऑन मे
सशन @ gmail.com कंटिन्यू प क्लिक करते
हैं ठीक है एंड यहां पे हम फॉरवर्ड पर
क्लिक कर देते हैं फॉरवर्ड फॉरवर्ड
फॉरवर्ड यहां पे आ चुके हैं हम ठीक है
एपीआई रिसेट पासवर्ड आ चुका है यह वाली
लिंक था यही वाली हमारी लिंक थी रिसेट
पासवर्ड की राइट क्लिक करते हैं यहां पे
सेंड टू सीक्वेंस कर देते हैं राइट क्लिक
करके सेंड टू इंट्रूडर कर देते हैं राइट
क्लिक करके सेंड
टू रिपीटर कर देते हैं ठीक है यहां पर हम
इसको फॉरवर्ड कर देते हैं कुछ और तो नहीं
है शायद रिक्वेस्ट व थी हमारी ठीक है बंद
कर देते हैं अब हमारे पास एक और मेल आ गई
होगी शायद मेरे ख्याल से जो
कि नो पासवर्ड रिसेट का ही होगा शायद
देखते हैं वी हैव गॉट अनदर मेल और नॉट
लेट्स सी कोई मेल हमें अभी एक मेल जो आई
थी वही मेल आई हुई है राइट हमें दूसरा मेल
शायद अभी नहीं आया या आ चुका है लेट मी सी
गाइस इफ वी गॉट वन मोर ईमेल नहीं हमें कोई
और ईमेल नहीं आई हुई है चलिए अच्छी बात है
अब हम यहां पे चल जाते हैं सीक्वेंस पे
सक्सर पे हम आएंगे तो यहां पे रिसेट
पासवर्ड का यहां पे आ चुका है लोकेशन यहां
पे एक लोकेशन है और एक लोकेशन यहां पे आई
है ठीक है रिसेट पासवर्ड का हमें कोई चीज
ना टोकन ना कुकी कुछ नहीं मिली है हम
स्टार्ट लाइव कैप्चर पर क्लिक करके एक बार
जस्ट देख लेते हैं इट विल नॉट वर्क आई
थिंक इन्होंने जो है वो मैकेनिज्म लगा रखी
है तो एक बार हम स्टार्ट कैप्चर पर करके
एक बार जस्ट ट्राई आउट कर लेते हैं जस्ट
गिव इट अ ट्राई ठीक है
ठीक
है क्लास क्लास में पूछ लीजिएगा चलिए यहां
पर अभी यहां पर तो कुछ हो नहीं रहा इंटर प
चलते हैं य इंर प लेट्स क्या हुआ यह आई
थिंक देर सम इशू कुछ बप शूट में लगिंग आई
है शायद देखते हैं थोड़ा वेट कर लेते हैं
20 के स्पेशल गिव अवे 20 के स्पेशल गिव
अवे तुम्हें नहीं लग रहा कि जो चीजें यहां
पर पढ़ाई जा रही है इतना कुछ सिखाया जा
रहा है यह एज अ गिव अवे कंसीडर करना चाहिए
तुम लोगों को नहीं लग
रहा इतनी चीजें बताई जा रही है बताओ हां
चलो अभी तो अभी तो हम बायपास टेक्निक प
आएंगे अभी
हम आई थिंक देयर इज सम देर सम इशू ये यहीं
पर लैग हो रहा है क्लोज कर देते हैं बब
शूट को क्लोज भी नहीं हो रहा वाओ बूट इ
नॉट गेटिंग क्लोज लगता है हैंग मार गया
थोड़ा कोई बात नहीं इसको बंद कर देते
हैं हां जी तो यहां पर हमारा इसके अंदर बब
शूट होगी शायद इसके
अंदर हां जी यह रहा बब शूट प्रोफेशनल इसको
हम एंड कर देते थोड़ी देर के लिए इट्स गट
एंड एंड हो चुका य हमारा तो बेसिकली दिस इ
आई थ यह पस्ड है एंड नो रेट लिमिट जो है
इस पर काम नो रेट लिमिट वटी इस पर नहीं है
ठीक है चलिए तो इसको हम यूज कर सकते हैं
एक बार ट्राई आउट करने के
लिए क्लोज नहीं
हुई भाई बंद हो जा यार क्या दिक्कत आ रही
है बताओ यार य यहां से तक बंद नहीं हो रही
है अब क्या कर सकते
हैं यस चलिए अब जाके ये बंद हो गई है अब
जाके ये बंद हुई है ठीक है लेट्स सी ना व
विल स्टार्ट द बॉब शूट
अगेन लेट्स स्टार्ट द बब शूट अगेन
ओके नहीं कैप्चा यहां पे तो नहीं था बट
ठीक है देख लेते हैं कोई बात नहीं लेट्स
सी वी कैन वी कैन सी दैट कोई प्रॉब्लम
नहीं है वी कैन सी दैट कोई दिक्कत नहीं है
ठीक है चलिए तो अब जो है ना यहां पर मान
लो यहां पे मान लो लेट्स सपोज क्या है कि
यहां पर हमारा नो रेट लिमिट अवेलेबिलिटी
नहीं है एंड इट्स अ पैस्ड ठीक
है ठीक है समझ में आ गया आई एम गुड आई एम
गुड आई एम गुड ये समझ लो अब इस बायपास
करने के टेक्निक्स देखते हैं चलिए अब यहां
पर मैं आपको इसके बायपास टेक्निक्स पर
लेकर चलता हूं तो सबसे पहले मैं यहां पे
नो रेट
लिमिट बायपास के कुछ टेक्निक्स आपको
समझाता हूं पहले ठीक है उस चीज को समझिए
ध्यान दीजिएगा इधर सभी लोग
प्लीज
ओके नो रेट लिमिट बायपास जब भी कहीं पर
कोई किसी प्रोग्राम प आपको रेट लिमिट
मिलती है तो आप उस रेट लिमिट को बायपास कर
सकते हैं ट्राई कर सकते हैं बायपास करने
का बायपास करने का सिंपल सा तरीका क्या
होता है मतलब क्या हो जाता है ना कि सर्वर
ने बहुत सारे रिक्वेस्ट के लिए क्या कर
रखा है सर्वर ने बहुत सारी रिक्वेस्ट के
लिए एक लिमिट लगा रखी है अब आप उसको
बायपास करके सर्वर को बहुत सारी रिक्वेस्ट
भेज पाओगे मतलब आपको कुछ ऐसा करना है
जिससे कि आप सर्वर को बहुत सारी रिक्वेस्ट
फिर से भेज पाओ अब सर्वर क्या करता है ना
मल्टीपल चीजें करता है एक क्या कि कौन सी
आईपी से रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है आईपी को ब्लॉक
कर देगा एक क्या कौन से सेशन से बारबार
रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है सेशन को ब्लॉक कर देगा
मतलब एक सेशन में आप चला ही नहीं पाएंगे
रिक्वेस्ट ही नहीं कर पाएंगे दूसरा क्या
एक जो पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट है वह एक बार
ही आ रही है मल्टीपल टाइम नहीं जा पाएगी
तो उस समय आपका वह रिक्वेस्ट ही प्रॉपर
ब्लॉक हो जाएगा अगर एक ब से ज्यादा जाती
है सेम पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट तो फिर आपका
वो ब्लॉक हो जाएगा तो यूजर बेस आईपी बेस
सेशन बेस इस तरह के जो टेक्निक्स है यूज
किए जाते हैं टू अप्लाई रेट लिमिट
टू एनी एप्लीकेशन अब इसका जो एक तरीका है
एक एग्जांपल मैं बता देता हूं कुछ
सिक्योरिटी हेडर्स होते हैं जैसे कि ये
यहां पर आपको दिख रहा होगा यहां पे ये
सबसे नीचे में जो है ना ये सिक्योरिटी
हेडर्स सबसे नीचे में जैसे एक्स रीकैप्चर
टोकन ये एक हेडर होता है एक्स सिक्योरिटी
टोकन ये एक हेडर होता है इस तरह के हेडर्स
अप्लाई किए जा सकते हैं या एक्स रेट लिमिट
लिमिट हेडर होता है उसको अप्लाई किया जाता
है टू सिक्योर द वेब एप्लीकेशन फ्रॉम नो
रेट लिमिट अटैक्स ठीक है अब इसी तरीके से
यहां पे राइट साइड में आप देखेंगे बायपास
हेडर में आप क्या लगा सकते हैं एक्स
डिसेबल्ड रीकैप्चर इससे आप रीकैप्चर को
डिसेबल कर सकते हैं सिक्योरिटी टोकन को भी
बायपास करने के बहुत सारे तरीके होते हैं
वो जैसे-जैसे आप आगे करते जाएंगे थोड़ा
माइंडसेट डेवलप होगा तो आपका जो माइंड है
जो आपकी जो जो माइंडसेट है वो डेवलप हो
जाएगी एंड आप भी फिर अलग-अलग तरह के जो
टेक्निक्स है उसको यूज कर पाएंगे बस सिंपल
सा फंडा है सारा है माइंडसेट का गेम है सब
कुछ और कुछ भी नहीं है माइंडसेट जितना
आपका डेवलप हो जाएगा उतना ही आपको जो
सक्सेस है वो मिल जाएगी ठीक है सबसे पहले
अब हम हेडर्स के अंदर यह कुछ जो रिक्वेस्ट
हेडर्स है इनको यूज करके हालांकि नॉट
लिमिटेड टू दिस ओनली और भी बहुत सारे
हेडर्स होते हैं आप रेट लिमिट को बाईपास
कर सकते हैं ठीक है बात को समझिए बस सिंपल
सिंपल बात को समझिए ठीक है एकदम सिंपल
सिंपल तो यहां पे
नो अ
लगता है यहां
पर कौन है यार यह टीएम फोटो एडिटिंग क्या
कर रहे हो भाई इतना क्यों स्पैम कर रहे हो
आप पहले यह बताओ टीएम फोटो एडिटिंग आप
स्पैम क्यों कर रहे
हो
स्पैम करोगे तो आपको टाइम आउट प डालना
पड़ेगा दूसरा ऑप्शन हमारे पास कोई नहीं है
ठीक
है स्पैम मत किया करो प्लीज डिस्टर्ब होता
है ना उसे ठीक है चलिए टाइम आउट पर कर
दिया स्पैम करोगे टाइम आउट कर कर देंगे
हमारे पास तो थोड़ी पावर है तो उसको यूज
कर लेंगे चलिए तो यहां पे अब हम इन हेडर्स
को लगा के अपने जो भी हेडर हेडर्स का मतलब
क्या है सिंपल सा भैया जो भी आपकी
रिक्वेस्ट होती है यहां पे आपका जब
रिक्वेस्ट होती है आप जब रिपीटर प जाते हो
तो यहां पे एक रिक्वेस्ट हेडर होती है और
यह रिस्पांस हेडर होता है ठीक है तो
रिक्वेस्ट हेडर्स में आप यह हेडर्स को यूज
करके एंड आप बाईपास कर सकते हो अब इस हेडर
का मतलब क्या है मैं आपको वो समझा देता
हूं सिंपल सा ठीक है मैं हेडर्स का मतलब
समझा देता हूं जैसे
देखो यहां पे एक्स फॉरवर्ड फॉर हेडर है
ठीक है अब इसका मतलब क्या है जैसे यहां पे
एक्स
फॉरवर्ड फॉर हेडर है अब यहां पे
12701 अब इसका मतलब क्या है ना कि तुम
ओरिजिन को चेंज कर रहे हो ओरिजिन तुम अपनी
आईपी को चेंज कर रहे हो तो यहां पे तुम
दिखा रहे हो कि भैया इस आईपी से रिक्वेस्ट
ये जा रही है अब इसको तुम बारबार मान लो
ये आईपी ये भी ब्लॉक हो गया लेट्स सपोज
दिस आल्सो गॉट ब्लॉकड तो इसको टू कर दो
इसको थ्री कर थ्री कर दो इसको फोर कर दो
ऐसे कर कर के यू हैव टू चेंज एंड यू हैव
टू ट्राई एंड ट्राई कि किस पे बायपास हो
जा रही है एंड किस पे मल्टीपल ईमेल्स
ओटीपी या कमेंट्स या जो भी है वो जानी
शुरू हो जा रही है तो यह एक तरीका है
जिसका यूज करके आप रेट लिमिट को सिंपली
क्या कर सकते हो बाईपास कर सकते हो
अलग-अलग हेडर्स का यूज करके ठीक है सिंपल
सा फंडा अब नेक्स्ट मैं आपको बताता हूं
रेट लिमिट जो है वो कौन-कौन से पेज पे
फाइंड किए जाते हैं ये तो आपको पहले भी
बता दिया है यहां पे भी आप देख ही लॉगिन
पेज हो गया रिसेट पेज हो गया रिसेट
पासवर्ड पेज हो गया साइन अप पेजेस हो गए
ओटीपी जनरेशन पेज हो गया या कमेंट्स हो
गया चैट हो गया अकाउंट कंफर्मेशन मेल हो
गई या कुछ भी व्हाट
एवर यह आप यहां पे पा सकते हो अब यहां पे
और तरीके जो है बायपास करने के रेट लिमिट
के उनमें से कुछ यह है कुछ स्पेशल बाइट्स
को ऐड करके कुछ स्पेशल बाइट्स को ऐड करके
इस टाइप के बाइट्स परसेंट 00 पर 0d पर 0a
पर 0 डी पर 0a पर 09 पर 0c इस टाइप के
कैरेक्टर्स जब आप ईमेल के एंड में ऐड कर
देते हैं यानी जो भी ईमेल आईडी जिस पे कि
आप चाहते हैं कि रेट लिमिट को बायपास किया
जाए ठीक है अब जब रेट लिमिट आप कहीं पे भी
कैप्चर करेंगे ना कोई एक रिक्वेस्ट को
जैसे मान लो आपने पासवर्ड रिसेट का मेल
किया तो आपने ईमेल आईडी डाली पासवर्ड
रिक्वेस्ट वाले रिक्वेस्ट को कैप्चर कर
लिया कैप्चर करोगे तो वहां पे ईमेल आईडी
वाली जो रिक्वेस्ट है वो आ जाएगी अब ईमेल
के आगे यह वाली जो पर्टिकुलर ब्लैंक
बाइट्स है आप लगा के चेक आउट कर सकते उस
रिक्वेस्ट को फिर भेज के एंड फिर उसको
मल्टीपल टाइम्स भेज के आप चेक आउट कर सकते
हो कि भैया यह काम कर रहा है कि नहीं कर
रहा है एज सिंपल एज दैट ठीक है तो यह काम
आप कर सकते हो या तो आप ब्लैंक स्पेस दे
सकते हो आफ्टर ईमेल आईडी ईमेल आईडी के बाद
में ब्लैंक स्पेस करके भी दे सकते हो ठीक
है अभी ले लो एसएस अभी ले लो अभी पीपीटी
का तो लेते रहा हो ना
एस पीपीटी का लेता बायपास करते हो रेट
लिमिट तो वो पी थ या प2 कैटेगरी में आ
सकती है डिपेंड करती है या अ किस टाइप का
जो आप बायपास कर रहे हो वह कहां पे कर रहे
हो मतलब वयर यू आर डूइंग वयर यू आर ट्राइट
बायपास ठीक है कौन सी पर्टिकुलर
फंक्शनैलिटी को बायपास कर रहे हो उसके बाद
अटैक अक्रॉस डिफरेंट अकाउंट ऑ सेशन इफ
इसका मतलब यह है कि इफ अ सर्वर हैज
अप्लाइड रेट लिमिट्स ऑन अ पर अकाउंट और पर
सेशन बेसिस डिस्ट्रीब्यूटर और टेस्ट
अक्रॉस मल्टीपल अकाउंट्स और सेशन कैन बी
हेल्प इन अवॉइडिंग डिटेक्शन मतलब अगर कोई
पर अकाउंट या पर सेशन बेसिस का कोई अगर
रेट लिमिट लगा हुआ है तो आप मल्टीपल
अकाउंट्स से उसको ट्राई आउट कर सकते हो
यानी डिफरेंट डिफरेंट अकाउंट से जैसे एक
अकाउंट है मा उसपे रेट लिमिट लगी हुई है
तो आप मल्टीपल अकाउंट से ट्राई करो यू
जस्ट ट्राई आउट विद मल्टीपल अकाउंट्स वो
भी रेट लिमिट बायपास करने के लिए यूज़ में
लिया जा सकता है ठीक
है बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल
प्रॉक्सी नेटवर्क्स का दूसरा तरीका क्या
है फिर तीसरा हमारा प्रॉक्सी नेटवर्क का
यूज़ करके जैसे कि क्या मैंने आपको बताया
कि आईपी बेस लिमिट भी लगी होती है रेट
लिमिट अब मान लो आईपी बेस लिमिट लगी है तो
आपकी आईपी ब्लॉक हो जाएगी सिंपल सा फंडा
है तो इसको सरकमवेंट्स का यूज़ करके और
उसको रेगुलेट कर दो यानी कि उसको चेंज
करते रहो कुछ-कुछ टाइम पे रोटेट करते रहो
या तो फिर आप क्या कर सकते हो डिफरेंट
डिफरेंट मल्टीपल आईपीस का यूज़ कर सकते हो
बहुत सारी फेक आईपीस जो हैं वो मिलती है
आईपी जनरेटर मिलती हैं आप उन आईपी जनरेटर
का यूज़ कर सकते हो सिर्फ फेकनेस दिखाने
के लिए और फिर यह चीज कर सकते हो ओके
बिल्कुल बिलकुल प्रॉक्सीस का यूज़ कर सकते
हो आप चाहो तो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है और
लास्ट में एक जो है आपका यूजिंग आईपी
रोटेट बर्प एक्सटेंशन अब इसका भी आप यूज
कर सकते हो आईपी रोटेट बर्प एक्सटेंशन का
बेसिकली ये बप एक्सटेंशन क्या करता है
आपके एड आपके इसके लिए आपके पास एडब्ल्यू
एस का अकाउंट होना चाहिए एडब्ल्यू के आपका
यूज करता है एडब्ल्यूएल एस के डिफरेंट
डिफरेंट रीजन से आपको आईपी उठा के देता है
और उसी आईपी से वो रिक्वेस्ट जाती है
जिसके कारण क्या होता है कि सामने वाले
सवर को लगता है कि मल्टी अलग-अलग यूजर्स
जो हैं वो कर रहे हैं हमारे को रिक्वेस्ट
तो वह आराम से रिस्पॉन्ड कर करता है ठीक
है तो याद रखिएगा कि एडब्ल्यू का जब आप
आईपी रोटेट यूज करेंगे एडब्ल्यू का तो कुछ
फ्री होती हैं अ जो आपको आईपीस मिलेंगी बट
उसके बाद जो है वो पेड होती है तो उसकी
प्राइसिंग वगैरह ध्यान देके देखिएगा अब
जैसे मैं आपको इसका एक एग्जांपल भी बता
देता हूं कोई प्रॉब्लम नहीं है
हां मैं आपको आईपी रोटेट वाला बता देता
हूं सिंपल सा कैसे आपको कॉन्फ़िगर करनी है
वो बता देता हूं आप लोग ट्राई जरूर
कीजिएगा ठीक है जैसे कि बब शूट को ओपन कर
लीजिएगा बब शूट को जैसे अगर पुराना
वर्कसूट है आपका तो यहां पर एक्सटेंडर
वाले ऑप्शन पे आपको बी एप स्टोर मिलेगा
ठीक है बी एप स्टोर इस पर चले जाइएगा बी
एप स्टोर पे ठीक है यहां पे बी ए स्टोर प
जाइएगा यहां पे नीचे आइएगा यहां पे नीचे
नीचे नीचे नीचे नीचे आई वाले सेक्शन में
आईपी रोटेट नाम का एक एक्सटेंशन मिल जाएगा
यह रहा आईपी रोटेट ठीक है तो बेसिकली आईपी
रोटेट वाली जो एक्सटेंशन है इसको इंस्टॉल
कर लीजिएगा यहां पे क्लिक कीजिएगा इंस्टॉल
हो
जाएगा बिल्कुल बिल्कुल हो सकता है
यह आईपी रोटेट जो है पोर्ट स्विगर का ही
एक एक्सटेंशन है तो ट्रस्टेड है कोई
दिक्कत नहीं है ये इंस्टॉल हो चुका है
इंस्टॉल होने के बाद यहां पे आईपी रोटेट
जो है यहां पे आ चुकी यहां पे आपकी आ चुकी
है ठीक है यहां पे आईपी रोटेट आ चुका है
अगर बाय चांस यह नहीं आता है जब आप
एक्सटेंडर में जाएंगे ऑप्शंस पे जाएंगे
यहां पे सॉरी यहां पे एक्सटेंशंस पे
जाएंगे तो यहां पे आईपी रोटेट वाली जो है
ये यूज टिक लगा होना चाहिए ठीक है टिक लगा
होना चाहिए अगर ये टिक लगा नहीं है तो टिक
कर ली लीजिएगा टिक करने के बाद अगर कोई
एरर आती है या नहीं यहां पर आ जाता है इस
पर्टिकुलर सेक्शन में आईपी रोटेट इसका
मतलब है आपके बब सूट के अंदर जाइथन नाम का
जो एक टूल है वो कन्फर्ट नहीं है जाइथन
करके आता है एक यूटिलिटी है वो
कन्फर्ट के आप पाइथन के कोई भी एक्सटेंशन
को बब शूट में यूज जनरली नहीं कर पाएंगे
ठीक है जनरली ऐसा ऐसा है ठीक
है ठीक है भाई ठीक है निलेश मत बार-बार
मैसेज मत करो ब्लॉक करना पड़ेगा फिर आपको
भी ऑलरेडी है
whatsapp2 आ चुकी है अब वो जाइथन का कैसे
है सेटअप एक्सटेंडर पे जाइएगा यहां पे
एक्सटेंडर पे आइएगा ठीक है एक्सटेंडर पे
आना चाहिए ठीक है एक्सटेंडर पे आ जाइएगा
यहां पे स्टैंडर पे आके यहां पे
अ ऑप्शंस पे आइएगा ऑप्शंस पे तो यहां पे
आपको जावा एनवायरमेंट का एक ऑप्शन मिलेगा
एक python2 का मिलेगा एक रूबी एनवायरमेंट
का मिलेगा ठीक है तो जब आप
pythonanywhere.com
आ जाइएगा ऑप्शंस पे एंड यहां पे आप
सेलेक्ट फाइल कर लीजिएगा python2 के अंदर
में सेलेक्ट फाइल कर लीजिएगा एंड जाइथन
वाली जो फाइल है उसको सेलेक्ट कर लीजिएगा
तो यहां पे आ जाएगी जैसे मेरी यहां पे
डाउनलोड्स के अंदर जाइथन स् अनज फाइल है
ये है तो यहां पे मैंने सिलेक्ट कर लिया
दैट्ची ना आईपी रोटेट का मतलब आपकी
बार-बार आईपी चेंज हो रही है ना आईपी
डिफरेंट आईपी से रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है
डिफरेंट आईपी से आपके रिक्वेस्ट जा रहे
हैं तो सामने सर्वर को लगेगा कि अलग-अलग
यूजर हमसे कांटेक्ट कर रहे हैं हम हमको
रिक्वेस्ट कर रहे हैं तो रिस्पॉन्ड करेंगे
ठीक है तो वहां पे रेट लिमिट बायपास हो
जाएगा उनका बस रेट लिमिट का मतलब वही होता
है यार कि एक यूजर मल्टीपल रिक्वेस्ट भेजे
तो उसको रिजेक्ट करना है बट अगर वही यूजर
मल्टीपल आईपीस का यूज करके रिक्वेस्ट भेज
रहा है तो वो बायपास हो गया अब यहां आईपी
रोटेट आ गई अब यहां पे आपको क्या करना है
अपने एडब्ल्यू एस अकाउंट से जो भी आपने
फ्री टियर आप फ्री टियर का यूज कर सकते
हैं एडब्ल्यू एस का आपको खरीदने की जरूरत
नहीं है फ्री टियर में बहुत सारे जो जो
आईपी मिलेंगे वो फ्री मिल जाते हैं तो
यहां पे आप उसका एक्सेस की आपसे सेटिंग
में एडब्ल्यू एस के सिक्योरिटी सेटिंग्स
में देखिएगा एक्सेस की आपको रहता है आपका
तो एक्सेस की डाल दीजिएगा फिर सीक्रेट की
डाल दीजिएगा एंड यहां पे जो टारगेट होस्ट
है जिस पे कि आप ये काम करना चाहते हैं वो
डाल दीजिएगा एंड यहां पे उसके बाद इनेबल
कर दीजिएगा ठीक है जब इनेबल कर दीजिएगा यह
काम चालू हो जाएगा उसके बाद आप ये आईपी
रोटे रोटेशन वाला काम कर सकते हैं डिसेबल
कर देंगे आपकी जो भी आईपी जनरेट हुई होंगी
वो डिलीट हो जाएंगी एंड आप सेफ रहेंगे
एडब्ल्यू एस से तो ये आप कर लीजिएगा ठीक
है याद रखिएगा आपका फ्री टियर होना चाहिए
और रियल क्रेडिट कार्ड एडब्ल्यू एस में
यूज मत कीजिएगा बिल आ जाती है बहुत
सारी ठीक है चलिए तो यह तो एक तरीका यह एक
तरीका हो गया आपका जिससे कि आप आईपी रोटेट
करके आप ये चीज कर रहे हैं अब ओटीपी
बायपास मान लो लेट्स सपोज किसी लेट्स सपोज
क्या होता है ओटीपी बायपास करके भी ये चीज
आप दिखा सकते हैं कोई एक कंपनी है जिसका
लॉगइन ओटीपी से होता है और ओटीपी चार
डिजिट की आ रही है ओनली ओनली फोर डिजिट
ओटीपी आ रही है मान लो लेट्स सपोज ठीक है
ओनली फोर डिजिट अब जब ओनली फोर डिजिट की
आईपी आएगी जस्ट फॉर योर इंफॉर्मेशन तो उस
परे हम क्या कर सकते हैं वी कैन
ट्राई ब्रूट फोर्स अटैक ब्रूट फोर्स अटैक
कब पॉसिबल है जब रेट लिमिट वहां बायपास हो
जाए या रेट लिमिट वहां नहीं चाम कर रही है
तब वो ब्रूट फोर्स अटैक जो है वो
एप्लीकेबल वहां पे हो जाएगा ठीक है फिलहाल
के
लिए यहां पे फॉरगॉट यो ईमेल पासवर्ड यहां
पे मैं आई एम नॉट रोबोट कर देता हूं यहां
पे ठीक है एंड यहां पे इस रिक्वेस्ट को
कैप्चर अरे अरे अरे ये ऑटोमेटिक यहां पे
हो रहा है यहां पे ठीक है कोई बात नहीं
यहां पे मेरे पास फिर से आ गया एक
रिक्वेस्ट ठीक है कोई बात नहीं इसको क्या
कर देते हैं यहां पे चलते हैं क्रिएट
अकाउंट सॉरी फॉरगॉट ईमेल पासवर्ड अगेन वी
आर गोइंग टू मेक्स व सलूशन @ gmail.com य
हमने डाला एंड इस रिक्वेस्ट को कैप्चर
करेंगे
प्रॉक्सी प चलते हैं इंटरसेप्ट को ऑन कर
लेते हैं यहां पे कंटिन्यू कर देते हैं
जैसे हमने कंटिन्यू किया बप में यहां पे आ
चुके हैं यहां पे अब यहां पे फॉरवर्ड करते
हैं फॉरवर्ड करते हैं फॉरवर्ड करते हैं
कैप्चा आएगा क्या हां नहीं कैप्चा तो नहीं
आया इस बार लेकिन रिसेट पासवर्ड वाली जो
टोकन है यहां पे आ चुकी है हमारे पास राइट
क्लिक करते हैं सेंड टू यहां पे सीक्वेंसर
भेज देते हैं राइट क्लिक करके सेंड टू
इंट्रूडर भेज देते हैं यहां पे सब कुछ कर
देते हैं और इसको हम एक बार चेक आउट कर
लेंगे ना भाई कि क्या क्या दिक्कत है
इंट्रूडर और उसको सबको भेज दिया है रिपीटर
को भी भेज देते एक बार एंड यहां पे हम
इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ कर देते हैं ठीक है
इंटरसेप्ट को ऑफ किया यहां पे एंड अगेन
यहां पे कैप्चा है तो यहां कैप्चा है भाई
बिना इसके तुम नहीं कर सकते
हो चलो इसका एक बार कैप्चा वाला जो
टेक्निक है वो एक बार हम स्टडी कर लेंगे
वेरीफाई कर लेते हैं यहां
पे ठीक है यह चीज आ गई अब हम यहां पे
रिपीटर पे चलते हैं यहां पे रिपीटर वाली
टैब को थोड़ा सा एक्सपेंड कर देता हूं
यहां पे जब आप यहां पे रिपीटर पे आएंगे तो
यहां पे आप देख सते पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट जा
रही है एपीआई रिसेट पासवर्ड की ठीक है
यहां पे आ रही है नीचे आप आएंगे तो इसके
हेडर्स को देखिए अलग-अलग हेडर्स इसके
अलग-अलग हेडर्स देखिए एक तो होस्ट है आपका
यूजर एजेंट अच्छी बात है यहां पर आ रही है
कनेक्शन आ रही है रेफरर आ रही है अच्छी
बात है नीचे की तरफ आइए यहां
पे ओके सिक्योरिटी फेच साइट यहां पर आ रही
है देन कैप्चा समथिंग लाइक
दैट
हो कोई ऐसा कुछ है हेडर नहीं
है ठीक है तो यहां पे इस रिक्वेस्ट के
अंदर ना एक चीज क्या आ रही है हमारे पास
एक चीज आप ध्यान
रखिएगा एक चीज आ रही है डाटा जो है ईमेल
और डोमेन है यहां पे ठीक है अच्छी बात है
यहां टोकन आ रही है लास्ट में एक
वेरिफिकेशन ट्रू आ रहा है यह आ रही है
वेरिफिकेशन ट्रू करके य आ रहा
है ठीक है तो अब मैं यहां पे सीक्वेंसर पे
चलता हूं यहां पे सीक्वेंसर पे हम आ चुके
हैं यहां पे या इंट्रूडर पे चलते हैं और
हम इंट्रूडर पे आके ना मेल आईडी एक बार
चेक कर लेते हैं एक बार चेक कर लेते हैं
जस्ट
वेट इंटर आ जाते हैं पोजीशंस प आ जाते
हैं यहां क्लियर कर देते हैं एंड वी आर
गोइंग टू सेलेक्ट अ
पोजीशन तो यहां पे मैं एक कोई सा भी
पोजीशन को सेलेक्ट कर लेता हूं जैसे यह
पोजीशन हमने सेलेक्ट कर लिया यहां को हम
इसको मार्क कर देते हैं ठीक है यहां पे
हमने कर लिया अभ हम यहां पे पेलोड प चलते
हैं एंड यहां पे हम इसकी सिंपल लिस्ट जो
है इसको हम नंबर्स में सेलेक्ट कर लेते
हैं नंबर्स में नटू यहां पे 1000 दे देते
हैं एंड स्टेप वन कर देते हैं 1000
रिक्वेस्ट को जो है वो हम भेजते हैं
स्टार्ट अटैक पे क्लिक करते हैं एंड उसके
बाद देखते हैं क्या होता है तो हमने
स्टार्ट अटैक पे क्लिक किया एंड वी आर नाउ
सीइंग द मेल आईडी कि ये काम करता है कि
नहीं लेट्स सी तो दो ही रिक्वेस्ट आई थी
हमारी एंड दो ही रिक्वेस्ट है यहां पे
अ रिक्वेस्ट और नहीं आ रही है हमारे पास
रिसेट पासवर्ड की ओबवियसली नहीं आ रही है
तो दिस इज अ देयर इज नो रेट लिमिट राइट
यहां पे कोई रेट लिमिट नहीं है राइट
ये इसको भी जाने का मन है बेचारे को तो
इसको भी निकाल देते
हैं नीलेश पाटील जी को भी इनको भी यहां से
भगाते
हैं
चलिए यहां पर कोई भी मेल नहीं आ रही है
हमें राइट वी आर नॉट गेटिंग मेल्स वी आर
नॉट गेटिंग मेल्स हमें जो एक दो मेल आई थी
बस वही मेल है और कुछ भी नहीं है
राइट यहां से जो हमें दो मेल्स आई थी बस
वही है और कुछ भी नहीं है ओके सो देयर इज
अ देयर इज अ रेट लिमिट ये तो पता ये
कंफर्म हो गए आप लोग गाइस कि देयर इज अ
रेट लिमिट ये कंफर्म है आप लोग कि इस पे
रेट लिमिट लगी
है चलिए अब मैं यहां पे रिपीटर पे चलके इस
वाले पेज को भी बार-बार यहां पे इस
रिक्वेस्ट को सेंड करता हूं 200 ओके यहां
पे आप देखो यहां देखो 200 ओके आया मैंने
इसको भेजा इस रिक्वेस्ट को जब मैंने इस
रिक्वेस्ट को भेजा ध्यान
रखिए बिल्कुल बिल्कुल बिल्कुल सही मोहम्मद
बिलाल बिल्कुल सही यह काम हम कर सकते हैं
एब्सलूट राइट यही काम मैं अभी करने वाला
था एकदम सही जवाब अब हम यहां पे क्या कर
सकते हैं कि यहां पे हमने जब इसको ओके
किया तो यहां पे 200 ओके तो आ रहा है बट
यहां सक्सेस फॉल्स आ रहा है मैसेज
वैलिडेशन अनसक्सेसफुल आ रही है एंड यहां
पे रीकैप्चा फेल्ड आ रहा है तो एक काम कर
देते हैं कि डाटा तो चलो यहां पे ईमेल
डोमेन आ गया टोकन यहां पे आ चुकी है अब अब
हम क्या कर लेते हैं कि यहां वेरिफिकेशन
जो ट्रू है इसको फाल्स करके देखते हैं एफ
ए एल
एसई ठीक
है एफ ए एल एसई फॉल्स करके देखते हैं अब
वेरिफिकेशन फॉल्स किया हमने वेरिफिकेशन
फॉल्स करने के बाद नाउ वी विल सी द
रिस्पांस अब हमें रिस्पांस देखना है कि
क्या आता है लेट्स सी कुछ काम नहीं भी कर
सकता कर भी सकता देख लेते
हैं हो स्टेटस को 200 एंड सक्सेस ट्रू
गाइस सक्सेस इज ट्रू स्टैटस अब हम क्या
करते हैं राइट क्लिक करके इसको सेंड टू
सीक्वेंसर भेज देते हैं सेंड टू इंट्रूडर
भेज देते हैं सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी सॉरी इसी को
वापस भेज दिया
क्या सेंड टू इंट्रूडर भेज देते हैं अब हम
सीक्वेंसर पे चलते हैं ओबवियसली यहां पे
तो कुछ नहीं मिलेगा हमें हम यहां पे
इंट्रूडर पे आ जाते हैं राइट वी आर
इंट्रूडर कमिंग टू इंट्रूडर यहां पे
क्लियर कर लेते हैं पाथ को एंड यहां पे
हमारे वेरिफिकेशन फाल्स है हम यहां पे कोई
भी एक पर्टिकुलर जो है एंटिटी को यहां पे
ऐड कर देते हैं पे लोट्स पे चलते ते हैं
सिंपल लिस्ट को यहां पे नंबर पे कर देते
हैं एंड यहां पे
वनटू टू 1000 एंड वन स्टेप ठीक है ये हमने
कर लिया एंड अब हम स्टार्ट अटैक पे करते
हैं और देखते हैं क्या होता है और हम अपना
फोन जो है यहां पे ला देते हैं लेट्स सी
व्हाट इज
हैपनिंग इफ वी आर गेटिंग मेल र नॉट सबसे
बड़ी बात है कि मेल आनी चाहिए सबसे बड़ी
बात है कि वी शुड बी गेटिंग द मेल अगर वो
नहीं आया तो फिर कोई काम का नहीं है
तो आई थिंक अभी भी हमें नहीं आ रही
है लेट्स
सी मेल तो नहीं आ रही है राइट एंड य लेंथ
जो है इन सबकी ऑलमोस्ट सेम है
ओके ऑलमोस्ट सिमिलर ठीक है स्पैम में नहीं
है स्पैम में तो नहीं आ रही होंगी
शायद न नो स्पैम में नहीं है नहीं सही है
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है लेकिन हा एक चीज
बायपास तो हमने किया यहां पे एक चीज हमने
बायपास की है वो फॉल्स करके दैट इज वी हैव
बायपास तो दैट इज द गुड थिंग बट स्टिल वी
हैव टू ट्राई वी हैव टू ट्राई मोर तो हम
यहां पर क्या कर देते हैं
हम एक काम कर लेते हैं जस्ट जस्ट लेट्स सी
व्ट वी आर गोइंग टू डू ईमेल और डोमेन यहां
पर हमने मे सशन gmail.com डाला था एंड
यहां पर हमने चीज डाली थी एंड रिपीटर पर
चलते हैं यहां पे हमारा यहां पर सक्सेस
ट्रू हो रहा है तो एक काम कर लेते हैं
यहां पर एपीआई रिसेट पासवर्ड लिंक है ना
इसको हम बारबार इसको सेंड करते हैं
मैनुअली मैनुअली लेट्स चेक
मैनुअली लेट सी इफ वी आर गेटिंग द रिसेट
पासवर्ड र नॉट
नहीं वी आर नॉट गेटिंग तो यह यहां दिखा तो
रहा है बेसिकली बट इट्स
नॉट सेंडिंग द पासवर्ड
रिसेट य ईमेल इट्स नॉट सेंडिंग मेल आनी
चाहिए या इफ वी गेट ईमेल्स ऑफ आफ यस अगर
ये कुछ देर के बाद भी मल्टीपल आने लगते
हैं तो 100% इट विल बी अवेलेबिलिटी कुछ
देर के बाद भी अगर आते हैं बट अभी फिलहाल
हमारे पास नहीं आ रहे हैं मल्टीपल हमने
मैनुअली भी किया बट इट्स नॉट कमिंग सो वी
विल ट्राई इट अगेन वी विल ट्राई इट अगेन
नाउ लेट्स सी अब हम यहां पे क्या करते हैं
ना नाउ व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू डू हम यहां
पे अब कुछ छेड़छाड़ करने वाले हैं ताकि
हमें मेल आए हमें मतलब है मेल आने से भाई
और कुछ से मतलब नहीं है अब हम यहां पे
अपनी रेट लिमिट बायपास करने की अलग-अलग
टेक्निक्स को यूज करेंगे तो यूज किया जाए
यूज किया जाए क्या बताइए एक कैप्चा
प्रॉब्लम दे रही है थोड़ी सी और कैप्चा का
यहां पर कोई हेडर भी मुझे नहीं दिख रहा
हा जी सो व्ट वी आर गोइंग टू डू हमें एक
मेल आनी चाहिए बस उससे मतलब नहीं है हमें
बाकी चीज वेरिफिकेशन यहां पर हमने ट्रू से
फॉल्स किया है तो सक्सेस ट्रू हो गया
स्टेटस को जीरो हो चुकी है अगर हम इसको
वापस से ट्रू कर दे तो क्या आ रहा
य वापस से अगर हम इसको ट्रू करते हैं गो
पर क्लिक करते हैं व्ट वी आर
गोइंग रीकैप्चर फेल्ड आ रहा
है सक्सेस
फॉल्स आ रहा है वेफ वैलिडेशन अनसक्सेसफुल
आ रही है राइट यह चीज आ रही है अगर हम
इसको फॉल्स करते हैं चलो एक काम करते हैं
जस्ट कॉपी
इट जस्ट कॉपी इट यहां पर इसको हम फॉल्स
करते
हैं इसको सेंड करते हैं लेट्स सी स्ट जीरो
यह आ रही है तो एक काम करते हैं एक काम
करते हैं
ये रिस्पांस आ रहा है ना
हमारा ठीक है सेंड
टू इसको ना हम एक काम कर लेते
हैं यहां
पे इस पर्टिकुलर चीज को वी आर गोइंग टू
कॉपी पेस्ट हमने यहां से कॉपी किया इस इस
रिस्पांस को हम यहां पे पेस्ट कर लेते हैं
फिलहाल के लिए ठीक है
एंड वेरिफिकेशन वाली
कॉलम को रिमूव करके मुझे नहीं लगता यह तो
फिर आई डोंट थिंक इट विल वर्क इसलिए बिकॉज
यह एक रिक्वायर्ड कॉलम हो सकता है एंड अगर
हमने इसको हटा दिया तो यहां पर यह हमसे
बोल सकता है मिसिंग पैरामीटर का एरर दे
सकता है लेट्स सी अभी भी सक्सेस ट्रू हो
रहा है ठीक है हां जी यह काम कर रही है यह
काम कर रही है वेरिफिकेशन को हमने हटा
दिया उस कॉलम को ही हटा दिया
एंड हमने जब ओके किया वी गट द मेल थ्री
तीन मेल आ चुके हैं वी गट द मेल तीसरा मेल
आ चुका
है वेरिफिकेशन वाला हमने बल ब्लॉक ही हटा
दिया अब इसको मैनुअली तीन चार बार टिप
करता हूं मैं और देखता हूं मेल आता है कि
नहीं तीन बार आया हुआ है ना ठीक है अब
इसको क्या करते हैं मैनुअली एक
दो
तीन चार पाच छ छह बार किया हमने देखते हैं
देखते हैं आता कि नहीं तीन तो आए हुए मेल
लेट्स सी इफ य आर गेटिंग सम मोर मेल्स और
नॉट एक तो मेल आया है बट उसके बाद अगेन
इट्स नॉट
कमिंग आजा यार और भी आजा 200 सक्सेस ट्रू
तो आ ही गए हो तो और भी आ जाओ क्या दिक्कत
है अगेन आई थिंक इट्स द कैप्चा
इशू लेट से आएगा मे बी कुछ भी हो सकता है
कुछ भी हो सकता है बट अभी तीन ही
आया करेंटली इट्स ी ओनली चलो एक काम और
करते हैं लेट्स ड वन थिंग लेटस ड न
थिंग एक काम करते हैं जस्ट रिमूव इट रिमूव
इट सीक्वेंसर से इसको हम क्लियर कर देते
हैं इंट्रूडर से भी हम इसको
देते प्रॉक्सी पर चलते हैं सेम हमारे
टारगेट पर चलते हैं लेट्स गो टू द सेम
टारगेट वी हैव
हियर ठीक है लेट्स गो टू साइन इन
पेज लेट्स रिसेट
पासवर्ड अगेन यहां पर यह देखो यह
वेरिफिकेशन आ रही है इन्होने क्लाउड
फ्लेयर की यूज की है ओके
यहां ओके यह रिसेट पासवर्ड का है ट
पासवर्ड का नहीं है चलो ईमेल आईडी डाल
देते
हैं यहां कुछ अलग है यहां पर पैनल ठीक
है मे सशन @ gmail.com और यहां पर हम इसको
कैप्चर कर लेते
हैं लेट्स कैप्चर इट इंटरसेप्ट ऑन सेंड
मेल यहां पर रिसेट पासवर्ड आ गया यहां पर
सिर्फ ईमेल आईडी आ रही है बाकी कोई फीड आ
ही नहीं रही है यह देख रहे हो रिसेट
पासवर्ड सेंड मेल आ रही है यहां पर सिंपल
सा तो इसको हम क्या करते हैं राइट क्लिक
करते हैं राइट क्लिक करते हैं यहां पे
दूसरा कोई भी हमारे पास फील्ड नहीं आ रहा
है सेंड टू इंट्रूडर करते हैं सेंड टू
सीक्वेंसर करते हैं सेंड टू रिपीटर कर
देते
हैं ठीक है फॉर द फॉर नाउ अ बस इतना इतना
हम करके रखते हैं इसको ठीक है
एंड नथिंग एल्स ड्रॉप करते हैं इस
रिक्वेस्ट को यहीं पे ड्रॉप कर देते हैं
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है ड्रॉप कर देते हैं
इसको बैक कर लेते हैं एंड यहां पे रिपीटर
पे चलते हैं रिपीटर पे चलने के बाद हम
देखते हैं हमारे पास मेल कौन सी आती है
तीन तो आई हुई है
से ओके पासवर्ड रिसेट का एक मेल आया है
यहां पर लेट्स क्लिक ऑन द गो गो बटन लेट्स
सी व्ट इज
हैपनिंग लेट्स सी ट इ कैप्चा ओके 303 सी
अदर यहां पर में एक एरर आ रही है एंड ट्स
वई वी विल नॉट गेट सम अदर मैसेज ठीक
है हेलो हेलो लाल सादात कैसे हो पासवर्ड
रिसेट दो दो आ गया यहां प दो दो मैसेज आ
गए हैं दो बार आ चुके हैं सो व्हाट वी आर
गोइंग टू डू सीक्वेंसर प चलते हैं य पे
हमें कुकी मिली है सीक्वेंसर में
सीक्वेंसर में हमें कुकी मिली है नाउ
व्हाट वी आर गोइंग टू डू वी आर गोइंग टू
स्टार्ट द लाइव कैप्चर एंड लेट्स सी व्ट
इज
हैपनिंग लेट्स सी इफ य आर
गेटिंग मल्टीपल मेल्स फॉर दिस दो बार तो
आए हुए हमारे पास लेट्स
सी सात आ चुके
हैं क्या बात है क्या बात है गा 13 आ चुके
हैं
गाइस तो यहां पर 17 आ चुके हैं 19 आ चुके
हैं 21 आ चुके हैं पासवर्ड रिसेट है
यह पासवर्ड रिसेट है यह 27 आ चुके
हैं 29 आ चुके हैं अब बताओ 32 आ चुके हैं
35 37 क्या क्या लग रहा है
भाई 37 आ चुके हैं फिलहाल एक फॉर्म फीड
चेंज किया हमने बस ओनली मतलब हम फॉर्म फीड
दूसरे फॉर्म फील्ड से कर रहे थे और यहां
एक कुकी हमारे पास कैप्चर हुई है कुकी
कैप्चर होना काफी जरूरी है कुकी या कोई
फॉर्म फील्ड कैप्चर हो जाए तो हमने यहां
पे कुकी कैप्चर कर लिया एंड यहां से हम
सीक्वेंसर को चालू कर रहे हैं एंड वी आर
गेटिंग पासवर्ड रिसेट मेल्स गाइज यह देखो
जो पासवर्ड रिसेट मेल हमें उस तरीके से
नहीं मिल पा रही थी हमें यहां पे यूज द
लिंक बिलो टू सेट अ न्यू सप पासवर्ड द
लिंक विल एक्सपायर इन 10 मिनट्स हमें यहां
पे जो क्या था यहां जो मिले थे यहां पे
हमें जो मैसेज मिले थे वी हैव रिसेंटली
रिक्वेस्टेड टू रिसेट योर पासवर्ड टू
रिसेट योर पासवर्ड क्लिक ऑन द बटन ठीक है
तो नीचे आ रहा था यहां पे 8
74 गॉट
इट ओके बथुआ राजेश थैंक यू फ्रॉम बॉटम ऑफ
माय हार्ट सर योर वीडियोस हेल्प मी अ लॉट
आई हैव क्लीयर्ड थ्री मॉक टेस्ट एंड आई
हैव इंटरव्यू इन कमिंग वीक गॉड ब्लेस यू
थैंक यू ग्रेट टू नो गाइज ग्रेट टू नो कि
आप जैसे स्टूडेंट्स भी है यहां पर जो उनको
जिनको काफी हेल्प हो रही है बग बांटी
सीरीज से आई एम ग्लैड आई एम वेरी मच ग्लैड
सुन के इतना ही बहुत खुशी हो गई भाई खुशी
मिल जाती है दूसरा कुछ नहीं चाहिए ये देखो
100 पार हो गया भाई ये भाई ये 100 पार हो
गया अब
बोलो तो तुम यह समझ रहे हो ना कि हर एक
चीज पॉसिबल है यह समझ में आ रहा है ना कि
एवरीथिंग इज
पॉसिबल बस थोड़ा टाइम देने की जरूरत है
मैं लाइव क्लास में उतना टाइम तो दे नहीं
पा लाइव क्लास में ना कभी मैं इतना टाइम
दे पाऊंगा कि मैं बैठ के अब जैसे अगर मैं
अकेले कोई हंट करूंगा किसी प्रोग्राम पे
तो मेरे पास कोई लिमिट नहीं होगी मैं 5
घंटे 10 घंटे दूंगा उस प्रोग्राम पे एक
पर्टिकुलर वलने बिलिटी एक फंक्शनैलिटी पे
मैं 20-20 घंटे दे दूंगा तो मुझे दिक्कत
नहीं है लेकिन लाइव क्लास में इतना टाइम
नहीं दे सकते तो कभी-कभी कुछ मिल जाता है
कभी कुछ नहीं मिले कोई बात नहीं सीखना मेन
थिंग है आपका जो सीख रहे हो वो इंपॉर्टेंट
होना चाहिए कांसेप्ट इंपॉर्टेंट होना
चाहिए बाकी चीजें तो बस यूं ही है ठीक है
कोई बात नहीं तुषार कोई बात नहीं चलेगा
हेलो सर आई गट नासा हल ऑफ फेम एंड गट अ
क्रिटिकल बग इन बुंग कॉ हलाल सत मेनी
कांग्रेचुलेशन आप लोग लिंकन प क्यों नहीं
डालते यार आप जो फाइंडिंग करते हो लिंकन
पर डालो ना लोग भी देखेंगे कोई कंपनी आगे
हायर करेगी वह भी देखेगी कि भै आपने कहां
कहा क टी फाइंड कि और हमें टैग करो हमें
भी मजा आएगा हमें भी अच्छा लगेगा है
ना ओके
तुषार बदक शशांक 4005 देखो अभी यह चलता जा
रहा चलता जा रहा है गा चलता जा रहा है
मुझे यहां पर यह टोकन मुझे यहां पर स्टॉप
करना पड़ेगा नहीं तो यह पता चले कि यह भी
कई सारे मेल्स आते रह जाएंगे आते रह
जाएंगे है ना तो यहां पर यह चलता जा रहा
है य पर आप देख सकते हैं य
पे यू कैन सी र यह देखो ओ माय गॉड स्टॉप
कर देता हूं मैं इसको स्टॉप कर देता हूं
सो वी गट द वी गट द मेल्स यहां देखो 77 अभ
ये बढ़ रहे होंगे 87 अरे भाई
साहब तो इससे क्या सीखने को मिला आपको कि
जितनी फंक्शनालिस पे ट्राई करो ट्राई ऑन
एव्री ईच एंड एवरी
फंक्शनालिस
दैट्ची बट अगर बट रिसोर्स के लिए है
इंफॉर्मेशन के लिए तो हनी पॉट मत लगाओ कोई
मतलब नहीं है बट अगर तुम सिर्फ
स्पेसिफिकली उसके लिए करना चाहते हो तो
लगा दो और तो फीचर है वो तो ठीक
है सर मैं सीएसआरएफ वीडियो तक आ गया हूं
क्या इसको स्किप कर दूं क्या अरे तो देखो
ना वीडियो कोई बात नहीं देख लो इसको अलग
से देख लो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है कोई दिक्कत
नहीं देख लो अलग से देख लो इसको तो यहां
पे हमने स्टॉप कर दिया एंड ये स्टॉप हो
चुकी है तो फाइनली वीी गॉट द रेट लिमिट
यहां पे आपने देखा कि एक जगह हम इसको रेट
लिमिट हम इसका ये जो मेल है नहीं भेज पा
रहे थे वी वी वर नॉट गेटिंग द मेल्स बट हम
वेरिफिकेशन को फॉल्स करके फिर भी भेज पा
रहे थे कुछ-कुछ मेल्स यहां पे पर जब हमने
दूसरी वाली जो फॉर्म फील्ड पे हमने जब
यहां पे अटैक करा तो यहां पे बेसिकली हमें
ना ही कोई ऐसी मैकेनिज्म मिली ना कोई हमें
हेडर मिला ऐसा कुछ ना कोई वेरिफिकेशन
चीजें मिली कुछ नहीं मिली एंड वी वर एबल
टू डू दिस अब देखो दोनों में मैं आपको
डिफरेंस बता देता हूं यहां मैं बैक करता
हूं देखो क्या चीज है मैं आपको बताता हूं
एक बहुत ही शानदार यह फंक्शनालिस है इस
वेबसाइट के अंदर जिसने कोड करा है उसने
कुछ गड़बड़ी की है जो डेवलपर है उसकी गलती
आपको बता देता हूं ठीक है यहां पे जब ऐसी
चीज होती है ना तो डेवलपर की गलती का पता
चल जाता है तो मैं आपको ना डेवलपर की गलती
का आईडिया देता हूं मैं आपको यहां पे
इंटरसेप्ट ऑफ कर लेता हूं मैंने यहां पे
बैक किया है यहां बैक किया ठीक है यहां
बैक किया
ओके यहां हमने बैक किया यहां पे आ चुके
हैं हम यहां पे साइन इन प चल यहां पे साइन
इन प चलते हैं पहले साइन इन पे गए यहां पे
ठीक है साइन इन पे हम गए एसवी में ही लॉग
इन कर रहे हैं हम और कुछ नहीं है एसवी में
लॉग इन कर रहे हैं यहां पे लेकिन यह इनका
वर्जन टू पैनल है यहां पे जब आप फॉरगेट
ईमेल और पासवर्ड प क्लिक करते हो तो कुछ
इस तरह का आपको पेज मिलता है और यहां से
आपको पासवर्ड रिसेट मेल जाती है बट बट जब
आप इनके होम पेज पे आते हो होम पेज पे
यहां पे आप आते हो साइन इन पे और यहां
क्रिएट अकाउंट प क्लिक करते हो लेट्स सपोज
यहां पे चलते हैं क्रिएट अकाउंट पे
तो यहां पे क्या आ रहा है क्रिएट अकाउंट
का सेम पेज आ रहा है अब यहां पे गो टू
लेगासी साइन इन पेज का ऑप्शन है हम लेगासी
साइन इन पेज प चलते हैं एक बार एंड जैसे
ही लेगासी साइन इन पेज पे चलते हैं यानी
जो इनका पुराना वाला पेज है उस पे अगर हम
यहां पे रिसेट पासवर्ड करते हैं तो यहां
पे किसी तरह का कोई ऐसा जो अ लिमिट है वो
यहां पे नहीं है एंड सिंपली क्या कर सकते
हैं वी कैन बायपास दिस मतलब हम यहां पे
सिंपल रेट लिमिट जो है वो बायपास हो रही
है यहां पे इनकी रेट लिमिट नहीं है सेटअप
ही नहीं है बेसिकली मैं यही बोलू दूंगा
एंड यहां पे हम अपना रेट लिमिट लेबिलिटी
फाइंड कर लिया हमने ठीक है बस सिंपल सा
फंडा है आई स्पेंड 20 डेज ऑन जस्ट वन
फंक्शन जस्ट नेवर गिव अप गाइ बिल्कुल
बिल्कुल सही बिल्कुल बहुत बढ़िया हेलाल आई
एम वेरी मच
इंप्रेस्ड समय लिंकन हैव प्रॉब्लम्स तो
उसको ठीक कर लो लाल एंड प्लीज पोस्ट करो
हां बढ़िया
रहेगा पूछिए पूछिए पूछिए पूछिए ठीक है तो
ये फंक्शन टीज हमने यहां पे इश्यूज यहां
पे हमने देखा यहां पे ठीक है अब हम इसके
अगर मेन पेज पे भी चलते हैं साइन इन पे
चलते हैं मेन पेज पे तो यहां कैप्चा का
इशू आ रहा है आपने देखा होगा कैप्चा इशू
वी आर गेटिंग फॉरगेट पासवर्ड ईमेल पे कर
देते हैं यहां पे हम यहां पे मक्स
सॉल्यूशन डालते हैं मक्स वन सॉल्यूशन @
gmail.com हमने डाला यहां पे ठीक है भैया
mx1 सशन @ gmail.com ठीक है अब यहां पे
कंटिन्यू करने से पहले इसको हम यहां पे
कैप्चा को कंटिन्यू करते हैं यहां पे इसको
रिक्वेस्ट को कैप्चा करेंगे देखो जब हमने
रिक्वेस्ट कैप्चर की ना सबसे पहला
रिक्वेस्ट जो हमारा जो जा रहा है ये र
कैप्चा रिक्वेस्ट है आपका का ठीक है
रीकैप्चा रिक्वेस्ट है और कुछ भी नहीं है
तो हम क्या कर देते हैं रीकैप्चा यहां पे
और कोई हेडर है क्या कुछ इंटरेस्टिंग सा अ
नहीं ये तो
google2 s.com ठीक है भैया तो हम यहां पे
आ चुके हैं अब यहां पे हमें एक रीकैप्चर
जब हमने फॉरवर्ड कर दिया है तो यह चीज हो
सकती है ना कि हमें यह रीकैप्चर वाली चीज
हटानी पड़ेगी ठीक है तभी आपका ये आगे अलाउ
करेगा तो इंटरसेप्ट ऑफ करते हैं यहां पे
देखते हैं हमरा रीकैप्चर मिल रहा है
बिल्कुल रीकैप्चर यहां पे मिल रहा है
रीकैप्चर मिल रहा है ना अब मैं एक काम
करता हूं इंटरसेप्ट कौन करता हूं यहां
रीकैप्चर फिल फिल कर देता हूं पहले इसको
मैं फॉरवर्ड कर देता हूं फॉरवर्ड कर देता
हूं जितने भी री कपच वाली रिक्वेस्ट है
बोट्स है यहां पे ठीक है तो बोट्स को
बोट्स कहां पे है भाई ये इसमें बोट्स कहां
है यार एक तो यह है बोट तो यह है बोट एक
तो यह है बोट वेरीफाई कर लेते हैं यहां पे
यहां पे जो भी आ रही है फॉरवर्ड कर देते
हैं जो रिक्वेस्ट आ रही है कैप्चा वाली
इनको फॉरवर्ड करते हैं ठीक है यहां पे
फॉरवर्ड हो गई यहां पे हमरा र कैप्चा
फॉर्म फिल हो चुका है यहां पे अब जो है ना
हम यहां पे यहां आते हैं र कैप्चा पे
फॉरवर्ड कर देते हैं फॉरवर्ड कर देते हैं
अब देखो यहां पे रिसेट पासवर्ड का एक
हमारे पास आ चुका है अब ये जो रिसेट
पासवर्ड वाली जो यूआरएल आई है यहां पे आप
देख सकते हैं हमारा कैप्चा वाला काम हो
चुका है रिसेट वाली आ चुकी है राइट क्लिक
करेंगे एंड सेंड टू रिपीटर कर देते हैं
वापस से सेंड टू इंट्रूडर कर देते हैं एंड
सेंड टू सीक्वेंसर कर देते हैं इस बार
सीक्वेंसर में आप आओगे तो यहां पे हमें
कोई कुकी ओकी नहीं मिली है पहले वाली में
देखो कुकी मिली थी हमें जो पहला वाला इनका
वर्जन था तो हमें यहां पे कुकी मिल गई थी
तो हमारा काम हो गया था यहां पे कोई कुकी
वगैरह नहीं है अब यहां पे तुम्हें देखना
पड़ेगा इसकी पूरी की पूरी रिक्वेस्ट को
पढ़ो राइट क्लिक करो डू इंटरसेप्ट
रिस्पांस टू दिस रिक्वेस्ट इसके रिस्पांस
को पढ़ना है आपको राइट क्लिक करके इस
रिक्वेस्ट को रिस्पांस को पढ़ना है तो
राइट क्लिक करो डू इंटरसेप्ट रिस्पांस टू
दिस रिक्वेस्ट यानी इसके रिस्पांस को आपको
पढ़ना है तो चलिए एपीआई रिक्वेस्ट जा रही
है रिसेट पोस्ट रिक्वेस्ट जा रही है बहुत
सही है रेफरल यहां पे आ रहा है लॉगइन का
यहां पे लॉगइन स्ल लॉगइन यह रेफरल यूज़ हो
रहा है बढ़िया है कुकी यहां पे आपकी यहां
पे कुकी जो वैल्यू है वो यूज हो रही है
एंड यहां प ऑथेंटिकेशन टोकन एक यूज हो रहा
है आपको यहां पे दिख रहा होगा टोकन
एक्सपाइेशन यहां पे दे रखी है बैक एंड
यूजर यूयू आईडी दे रखी है सेशन आईडी जो है
यहां पे आपकी यूज हो रही है ठीक है
अलग-अलग तरह की यहां पे मेजर्स है जो यूज
हो रहे हैं डाटा आपका ईमेल और वेरिफिकेशन
यहां पे यहां पे वेरिफिकेशन देखो यहां पे
वेरिफिकेशन फॉल्स आ रहा है यहां
वेरिफिकेशन पहले ही फॉल्स आ रहा है चलिए
अब हम क्या करते हैं ना व्हाट वी आर गोइंग
टू डू यहां पे अब एक चीज करते हैं यहां पे
हम क्या करते हैं इस इसको हम इंटरसेप्ट को
ऑफ कर देते
हैं
ओके अब यहां पे हमें यह रिस्पांस आ रहा है
यह रिस्पांस आ रहा है सक्सेस ट्रू एंड ये
चीज तो हम यहां पे देखते हैं यहां पे मेल
हमारे को कुछ आया क्या ये देखो मेल चौथा
यहां पे आया हुआ हमारे पास ये वाली चौथी
वाली ये वाली मेल आई है चलो इसको हम पूरा
का पूरा डिलीट मार देते हैं ताकि जो नया
हमारे पास आए तो हमें पता चल जाए ठीक है
तो हम यहां पे अब ये रिस्पांस आ रहा है
हमें कोई दिक्कत नहीं है यहां
पे फॉरवर्ड कर लेते हैं कुछ नहीं है ठीक
है चलिए अब हम आ जाते हैं यहां पर रिपीटर
प रिपीटर पर जब हम आएंगे तो यहां पर जब हम
आएंगे तो यहां पर आपको पहले वेरिफिकेशन
फॉल्स आ रही है यहां पर सब कुछ यहां पर
ठीक है अब हम यहां पर गो प क्लिक कर देते
हैं गो प क्लिक करके यहां पर मेल देखते
हैं इफ वी आर गेटिंग अ मेल लेट्स सी इफ वी
गेटिंग अ पासवर्ड रिट मेल नहीं मिला
हम यहां नहीं मिला ठीक है यहां नहीं मिला
राइट हां ये सही बोले यार
यहां
पे
कंफर्म ठीक है अब यहां पे हमें नहीं आया
कोई दिक्कत नहीं है अब हम एक काम करते हैं
अब यहां पे बायपास टेक्निक्स को हम अप्लाई
करते हैं कौन-कौन से टेक्निक जो अभी हमने
यहां देखा था ठीक है तो सबसे पहले हम यहां
पे हेडर का यूज करते हैं हेडर्स बायपास जो
है वो ट्राई आउट करते हैं लेट्स ट्राई आउट
फॉर द हेडर बायपास हेडर बायपास में हम
क्या कर देते हैं यहां पे
एक्स कौन सी चीज लगाते एक्स फॉरवर्ड फॉर
यही वाले लगा के देख लेते हालांकि बहुत
कॉमन सी चीज है बहुत कॉमन है बट स्टिल
लगाते हैं एक्स
फॉरवार्डेड फॉर एंड यहां पे देते हैं
127.0 सॉरी
0.0.1 ये हमने यहां पे मेंशन कर दिया एक्स
फॉरवार्डेड फॉर्म में
12700 गो पे क्लिक करते हैं लेट्स सी इफ
यू आर गेटिंग मेल ट्रू सक्सेस हुआ है बट
यहां मेल आने चाहिए वहां सक्सेस होने से
मतलब नहीं है यहां मेल हमें आने चाहिए वी
हैव नॉट गट द
मेल कोई बात नहीं यहां पे हमें कोई मेल
नहीं मिली है कोई मेल नहीं आई है अब यहां
पे ना एक्स फॉर्डेड फॉर्म में एक्स
फॉरवर्ड फ फॉर में हम यहां पे कर देते हैं
एक फेक
आईपी
जनरेटर रैंडम आईपी जनरेटर उठाते हैं एक
बार
जनरेट आईपी कॉपी कर लेते एक
आईपी य आईपी डालते हैं यहां से गो पर
क्लिक कर लेते हैं लेट्स सी इफ वी आर
गेटिंग द
मेल नो नॉट गेटिंग द
मेल नॉट गेटिंग द मेल अब यहां पर काम करते
हैं यहां पर 12700 ही डालते
12702 गो प क्लिक कर लेते हैं लेट्स सी इफ
गेटिंग द मेल ये तरीका है ठीक है ना
बिल्कुल कर सकते हो कोई से भी नोटेशन यूज
कर लो कोई दिक्कत नहीं है चलिए यह मान लो
हमारा मान लो यह हमारा काम नहीं कर रहा
लेट सपोज इट्स नॉट वर्किंग अब हम डाल देते
य पर सिंपल एक्स फॉरवर्ड ओनली एक्स
फॉरवर्ड डाल के देख लेते हैं लेट्स सी फॉर
एक्स फॉरवर्ड इफ इट इज वर्किंग और नॉट ठीक
है गो पर क्लिक कर देते हैं हमें यहां पर
मेल आनी चाहिए एक एक मेल आ जाएगी तो अरे
एक मेल आ गई मेल आई अभी गाइस गाइस मेल आई
कि नहीं पहले ये बताओ मेल आई कि नहीं आई
अब मुझे बताओ अब मुझे बताओ मेल ला दिया ना
पहले मेल नहीं आ रही थी ला दिया कि नहीं
ला दिया एक ही आई ना लेकिन मेल तो ला दिया
नहीं आ रही थी अभी भाई सक्सेस और ट्रू
होने प भी याद रखना तो मेल आई अभी ठीक है
अब एक बार आई है मल्टीपल आए ना आए वो अलग
बात है लेकिन एक बार आई है भाई हमारे एक्स
फॉरवार्डेड लगाने
से अब यहां पे क्या कर देते हैं यहां
नेक्स्ट गो पे क्लिक करते हैं फिर से एक
बार गो प क्लिक कर देते हैं देखते हैं
दोबारा आता है कि नहीं लेट्स सी दोबारा
आता है कि
नहीं
आजा ओ आजा क्या है भाई आजा भाई एक और
आजा मुझे लग रहा है एक आईपी बेस्ड ये लाइक
इन द सेंस की एक से आ गई तो अभी दूसरी
नहीं आएगी तो मैं क्या करता हूं नावन की
जगह टू कर देता हूं
12702 ठीक है तो गो पे क्लिक करते हैं
देखते हैं टू पे किया मैंने आईपी चेंज
किया मैंने 127 001 की जगह पे 127 002 कर
दिया लेट्स सी व्हाट इज हैपनिंग इट इज
एक्सेप्टिंग र नॉट
गाइस ये देखो नहीं आ बताऊंगा बताऊंगा
यार अभी तक तो नहीं आई यार अभी तक नहीं आई
चलो इस पे नहीं आई च एक काम कर लेते हैं
ना थ्री नहीं चलो च फाइव कर देते
हैं चलो दो बार तीन बार मल्टीपल टाइम्स
इसको भेजता हूं रिक्वेस्ट कहीं एक बार आ
जाए ऐसा भी होता है तो लेट्स चेक गाइस
ना ना ना ना एक और को जाने का समय एक और
के जाने का समय आ गया
है बेचारे समझते नहीं है बेचारे को जाने
का मन करता है तो एक ही बार आई है चलो
यहां पे एक हमने ट्राई किया एंड एक जो
हमने ट्राई किया उसकी जगह से उसकी वजह से
हमें चीज मिल गई अब हम क्या करते हैं एक्स
फॉरवर्ड जो हमने यूज किया ना एक्स फॉरवर्ड
फॉर में हम पांच पर ट्राई कर लेते हैं या
छ प ट्राई कर लेते हैं छ प एंड य पर गो प
क्लिक कर देते हैं एक्स फॉरवर्ड फॉर में
लेटस सी इफ इट इ सेंडिंग और
नॉट ना ना ना
ना रे
हा हेलो आदित्य मैं बढ़िया तुम बताओ कैसे
हो कैसे
यह देखो यह नहीं हुआ यह हमारा काम नहीं कर
रहा कोई बात नहीं कोई दिक्कत नहीं यार दिल
छोटा नहीं करना एक फॉर्डेड होस्ट कर लेते
हैं क्या कर लेते गाइस एक्स फॉरवार्डेड
होस्ट अब कर लेते हैं एक्स
फॉरवर्ड
होस्ट हां जी तो एक्स पड होस्ट में वन
करते 12700 एंड गो प क्लिक कर लेते हैं
लेट्स सी इफ य आर गेटिंग अ मेल
एक्स होस्ट में नहीं आया कुछ भी नहीं आ
एक्स फड होस्ट में नहीं मिला कोई बात नहीं
कोई बात नहीं कोई बात नहीं भाई थक नहीं
एक्स रिमोट आईपी चलिए ये वाली भी ट्राई कर
लेते हैं एक बार वी आर गोइंग टू ट्राई फॉर
एक्स रिमोट आईपी एक्स रिमोट आईपी ठीक है
अ एक्स रिमोट
आईपी रिमोट अलग-अलग तरीके आपको यूज करने
यार आपको टाइम देना पड़ेगा ठीक है बिना
टाइम दिए नहीं होती है चीजें बग बाउटी के
अंदर में टाइम दोगे मस्त मजे में तुमको
रिस्पांस मिलेगा नहीं दोगे दिक्कत है भाई
दिक्कत है दिक्कत है भाई दिक्कत है एक
इसका भी नहीं आया ना आई भी चेंज कर लेते
हैं वन के जगह प टू डाल के देखते इस वाले
पर्टिकुलर रिक्वेस्ट से गो प क्लिक कर
लेते हैं लेट्स चेक लेट्स चेक लेटस चक लेक
नहीं इसमें भी नहीं आया हमारे पास न
न नहीं आया एक्स फड आईपी प भी नहीं आई
हमारी कोई बात नहीं यार टेंशन क्यों लेना
है एक्स क्लाइंट आईपी चेक कर लेते हैं
लेट्स चेक फॉर एक्स क्लाइंट
आईपी एक्स क्लाइंट आईपी गो पर क्लिक कर
लेते हैं अच्छा ईमेल आईडी हमारा दे रखा है
ना हा वो भी काम करेंगे हम एक वो वाला भी
काम करेंगे ईमेल वाली बायपास ट्राई करेंगे
ये तो हेडर बायपास ट्राई कर रहे हैं
हम नहीं मिल रहा भाई नहीं इसमें भी नहीं
है ओके प्रॉक्सी क्लाइंट आईपी यूज करके
देख लेते हैं एक्स फॉरवार्डेड में और
बेकार है वैसे करना होस्ट हम देख लिए वो
हमने देख लिया तो एक्स एक्स रिमोट एड्रेस
देख लेते हैं एक बार एक्स रिमोट एड्रेस
ठीक
है एक्स
रिमोट अबे यार यह स्क्रीनशॉट वाली क्यों आ
गई भाई तुम एक्स रिमोट
एडर यहां पे वन करते हैं मे तो फल्स है ना
भाई हा यहां पर गो प क्लिक कर लेते हैं
लेट्स
सी एक्स रिमोट एड्रेस प आ गया भाई एक्स
रिमोट एड्रेस पर आ गया फिर से एक एक फिर
से आ गया अपना एक्स रिमोट एड्रेस पर ठीक
है चलिए बढ़िया बात है अच्छी बात है एक और
भेज के देखते हैं गो पर क्लिक करते हैं एक
और भेजते हैं देखते हैं आता है कि नहीं
दूसरा
आजा भाई एक्स रिमोट एड्रेस पे एक आया इट्स
नॉट कमिंग तो लेट्स चेक चेंज द आईपी
एड्रेस लेट्स चेक नाउ दो को तीन किया
मैंने वव चेंज द
आईपी वकिंग
नॉट
नहीं ओके लेट्स गिव इट से आईपी गो पर
क्लिक कर लेते हैं एंड लेट्स सी इफ हैव गट
सम अर मेल अब एक काम करते ना इसको ऑटोमेट
वाला इंट्रूडर को भेजते हैं सेंड टू
इंट्रूडर बहुत ज्यादा टाइम खा रहा है य
सेंड टू इंट्रूडर इंट्रूडर प चलते हैं अब
इसको थोड़ा सा इसके ठिकाने लगाते हैं अब
यहां पर हमारी जो आईपी है ना यह वाली
12701 यह वाली इसको हम ऐड करते हैं यहां
पेलो सेट कर ते हैं यहां नंबर सेट कर लेते
हैं कहां गई नंबर
भाई नंबर सेट कर लेते हैं यहां पर इसको एक
से लेके एंड 5 तक डाल देते हैं सीक्वेंस
एक बार चला देते हैं स्टार्ट अटैक पर
क्लिक कर देते हैं लेट सी कोई आता है कि
नहीं आता
है कुछ अगर काम कर गए तो कुछ मेल्स आ
जाएंगे ब वही कुछ मेल्स आने से नहीं होगा
कंटिन्यू आने रहे आने रहने चाहिए कंटिन्यू
मेल्स आते रहने चाहिए एंड ट इज रेट लिमिट
बायपास लेट
ना ना ना ना ना ना ना ना ना नॉट वर्किंग
नॉट वर्किंग नॉट वर्किंग चलिए ये वाली चीज
तो काम नहीं करी है हम एकदम श्यर हो चुके
हैं इससे तो अब हमें वापस से रिपीटर प
चलना है भाई और हमें यहां पे एक और चीज
चेक करनी है प्रॉक्सी क्लाइंट आईपी हमें
चेक कर लेना है प्रॉक्सी क्लाइंट आईपी ठीक
है लेट्स चेक फॉर द प्रॉक्सी क्लाइंट
आईपी
प्रॉक्सी क्लाइंट आईपी ये हमने चेक करना
है एंड लेट्स गिव इट वन एंड लेट्स क्लिक
गो दो दो आए हुए थे देखते हैं इस बार आता
है कि नहीं
भाई
ओके नहीं आ रहा है इस परे मैं यहां पे
नाइन कर देता हूं प्रॉक्सी क्लाइंट आईपी प
गो प क्लिक कर देते हैं लेट्स सी इफ य आर
गेटिंग और नॉट
[संगीत]
या इट्स
पॉसिबल यह पॉसिबल है हो सकता है टाइम
इंटरवल टाइम इंटरवल कैन बी पॉसिबल बट ठीक
है देखते हैं देखते हैं टाइम इंटरवल कैन
बी पॉसिबल सो देखते हैं एक बार पहला जो
हमें मेल आया था वह आया था 821 पे दूसरा
आया था 826 प ओके देर देर देयर इज अ टाइम
इंटरवल आई थिंक टाइम इंटरवल इशू मे बी
देयर इज अ टाइम इंटरवल मे बी हो सकता है
हो सकता है पॉसिबल है हां जी पॉसिबल है
टाइम इंटरवल टाइम इंटरवल प्रॉब्लम हो सकता
है इट्स पॉसिबल देखते हैं यहां पे जस्ट
गिव इट अ ट्राई 500 हां क्क यहां प मिल
रही है ठीक है होस्ट टोकन यहां प आ रही है
और कुछ कर सकते हैं इसमें चलो मेल वाली एक
बार मेल वाली बायपास करके देखते
हैं कैसे हो भाई अ कैसे हो भाई आपकी
वीडियो देखकर आई एम एबल टू अंडरस्टैंड
डिफिकल्ट कांसेप्ट मैं तो बढ़िया हूं एकदम
बढ़िया एंड ग्लैड दैट यू आर गेटिंग थ्रू
डिफिकल्ट
कांसेप्ट ठीक है आई एम ग्लैड चलिए चलिए
यहां पे तो अब यहां पे ना एक ईमेल वाली
चीज ट्राई करके देख लेते हैं जब बट ये
टाइम इंटरवल से कोई फर्क नहीं पड़ता है इन
द सेंस कि अगर रेगुलर मेल्स अगर नहीं आ पा
रहे हैं इंटरवल भी लग जा रहे हैं तो हम
उसमें फिर कुछ नहीं कर पाएंगे राइट वी कैन
नॉट डू दैट कैन नॉट डू एनीथिंग विद दैट
ओके या बट हम ईमेल अभी बायपास करके एक बार
ट्राई आउट करेंगे वी विल ट्राई आउट टू
बायपास तो अब यहां पे ट्राई आउट टू बायपास
अब यहां पे एक बार गो पे क्लिक कर देते
हैं आई थिंक मेल आ जाएगी शायद
तीसरी ये कौन है भाई आयशा
गुप्ता चलो तो यहां पे तो मेल आई थिंक आ
जाएगी शायद
आनी चाहिए बट नहीं आई है तो कुछ हो सकता
है चलिए अब यहां परना एक बायपास और लगाते
हैं ईमेल आईडी वाली ईमेल बायपास लगाते हैं
चीजें करते हैं यहां पर एक टोकन वाली जो
फील्ड है ठीक है अब मैं एक काम कर देता
हूं वेरिफिकेशन वाली जो फील्ड है अपनी इस
पूरी वेरिफिकेशन फील्ड को यहां से हम
रिमूव कर देते हैं लेट्स रिमूव
इट लेट्स रिमूव इट एंड यहां पे प्रॉक्सी
क्लाइंट आईपी जो है यहां पर वन दे देते
हैं ए यहां पर हम गो प क्लिक कर देते हैं
देखते हैं यहां पे क्या होता
है लेट्स
सी यह कौन है
भाई सर आप बग फाइंड आउट करके मुझे सेंड कर
दो रिपोर्ट सेंड कर कर देना ठीक है भाई
ठीक है कर दूंगा कोई टेंशन मत लो ये
कैसे ये बोल रहा है बग फाइंड करके दे दो
बताओ यार ये अभी यहां पे
था चलिए यहां पे आ गए यहां पे नहीं
इनवैलिड जेसन इनवैलिड जेसन आ रहा है यहां
पे ओबवियसली इट इज इनवैलिड जेसन बिकॉज हम
यहां पे हमने यहां पे कॉमा दे रखा है अब
यहां पे गो पे क्लिक कर देते हैं हां जी
अब सक्सेस आ रहा है लेट्स
सी यस वी गट
हियर ठीक है अब यहां पे हम चलते हैं दो
तीन बार क्लिक करते हैं लेट्स सपोज लेट्स
सी अरे वो मेमन वमन नहीं है वो मेल ही
होगा वो पक्का
तीन बार ही आई है
ना चलिए अब एक काम कर लेते हैं यहां पर वी
आर गोइंग टू चेंज
समथिंग सबसे पहले
तो
लेट्स रिमूव दिस टोकन वैल्यू आई थिंक वी
शुड रिमूव द टोकन वैल्यू आल्सो टोकन
वैल्यू को हमें आई थिंक मेरे ख्याल से हटा
देना चाहिए था एक बार हटा के देखते हैं
क्या होता है क्या इंपैक्ट पड़ता है यह
देखते हैं टोकन को हटा देते हैं तो लेट्स
रिमूव द टोकन यर
एंड लेट्स मूव दिस आल्सो एंड ओनली ईमेल
वाली जो आपकी डाटा है वो रखते हैं एंड
यहां गो पर क्लिक कर देते हैं इनवैलिड जशन
आ रहा है यहां
पे ओके यहां पे शायद हमने कुछ एक मिस्टेक
की है अब गो प क्लिक करते हैं सक्सेस ट्रू
आ रही है लेट्स सी इफ यू आर गेटिंग मेल
टोकन को हमने हटा दिया है वी हैव रिमूव द
टोकन स्टिल वी आर नॉट गेटिंग ओके नॉट
डिपेंडेंट ऑन ट न दिस टोकन चलिए कोई बात
नहीं य
ओके अब यहां पर ना हम ईमेल आईडी जो है
हमारी ईमेल आईडी इसके लास्ट में हम कुछ
कीवर्ड्स ऐड कर देते हैं लेट्स गिव इट अ
कीवर्ड यहां पे लाइक सबसे पहले वी आर
गोइंग टू गिव अ ब्लैंक स्पेस ईमेल आईडी के
आगे एक ब्लैंक स्पेस दे देते हैं गो प
क्लिक कर लेते हैं दे देन देखते हैं हम
यहां
पे आल्सो वीी आर रिमूविंग द एक्स
एक्स्ट्रा जो हमारी हेडर है यहां पर हमने
डाली हुई है
उसको रिमूव कर देते हैं जो क्लाइंट आईपी
वाली हेडर है ना इसको हम रिमूव कर देते
हैं वी डोंट नीड दिस एंड गो प क्लिक कर
देते
हैं देर माइट बी टाइम बेस्ड ऑफ फ मिनट्स
राइट धन्यवाद धन्यवाद धन्यवाद
चलिए ओके नॉट गेटिंग हियर नॉट गेटिंग हियर
कोई बात नहीं कोई बात नहीं अब यहां पे हम
यहां पे स्पेस ब्लैंक स्पेस को हटा के एंड
वी आर गोइंग टू यूज़ सम अ ब्लैंक बाइट्स
यहां पे तो हम परसेंट 0 या परस ड यूज़
करके एक बार देख लेते हैं सो वी आर गोइंग
टू यूज़ परसेंट 00 एंड लेट्स ट्राई टू
बायपास इट गो पे क्लिक कर देते हैं ओके
व्हाट इज दिस स्टेटस को 400 अरे यहां पे आ
रहा है यहां पे द रिक्वेस्ट इज मेल
फॉर्म्ड यहां जो आ रहा है ये रिक्वेस्ट
मेल फॉर्म का कैटेगरी जो है यहां पे आ जा
रहा है यहां पे हमें जो आ रही है प्लीज
ट्राई अगेन विद द करेक्ट फॉर्मेट तो यहां
पे एक प्रॉब्लम आ रही है ठीक है कोई बात
नहीं कोई बात नहीं परसेंट जीरो करके एक
बार देख लेते हैं कोई दिक्कत नहीं है गो
पे क्लिक कर देते हैं अगेन फॉर्मेट वाली
एरर आ
जाएगी तो यह चीज हम यहां पे तो लगा नहीं
सकते हैं बिकॉज इट्स गेटिंग डिटेक्टेड
ठीक है ब्लैंक स्पेस पे हमने किया था बट
हमें कुछ ऐसा कुछ नहीं मिला यहां पे ठीक
है तो आप इन चीजों का ब्लैंक बाइट्स का भी
यूज कर सकते हैं ब्लैंक स्पेस का भी यूज
कर सकते हैं जो भी आप चाहे आप यूज कर सकते
हैं वो आपकी मर्जी है ईमेल आईडी के बाद
ईमेल आईडी के बाद आप ने ब्लैंक स्पेस यूज़
किया एंड गो पे क्लिक किया तो यहां पे
सक्सेस आ रहा है अ यहां पे मेल नहीं आएगी
यहां पे बेसिकली तो यहां रेट लिमिट तो लगी
हुई है ये 100% गारंटी है इस बात की इनके
पुरानी फंक्शनैलिटी पे वो रेट लिमिट
बायपास हो रही थी मतलब वहां पे वो काम
नहीं कर रही थी आप वहां पे वो रेट लिमिट
फाइंड कर भी पा रहे थे ठीक है बट यहां पे
न्यू वाली फंक्शनल पे रेट लिमिट लगी है अब
आप इसको एज अ टास्क लीजिए या जो भी लीजिए
क्योंकि इसमें टाइम लगेगा हो सकता है
बायपास हो जाए ठीक है मैं ये नहीं बोल रहा
कि आप बायपास कर ही पाएंगे या बायपास हो
ही जाएगा जब भी कोई सिक्योरिटी लगी होती
है किसी वेबसाइट पे तो वो जरूरी नहीं है
कि बायपास हो ही जाए उसी टाइम पे हां यह
मैं जरूर बोलूंगा कि एवरी सिक्योरिटी इज
ब्रीचेज की जा सकती है अंट्स की दैट
सफिशिएंट टाइम दैट सफिशिएंट एफर्ट इज गिवन
टू दैट पर्टिकुलर थिंग सो उतना टाइम अगर
कोई देता है तो तो अगर आप इसको ट्राई आउट
कीजिएगा अगर उतना टाइम दे रहे हैं तो
ट्राई आउट कीजिए कि हां भैया ये चीज
बायपास हो जाए अगर बायपास हो जाती है तो
वेल एंड गुड अगर जिसका भी बायपास हो जाए
इसी डोमेन की मैं बात कर रहा हूं आई एम
जस्ट गिविंग दिस डोमेन ओनली एंड द डोमेन
इज v.com या ठीक है अगर बायपास हो जाए तो
बग बांटी हंटर वाली जो ग्रुप है ठीक है जो
ग्रुप है दूसरी वाली ग्रुप उस ग्रुप में
आपको मैसेज करना है या आप मैसेज डाल
दीजिएगा उस ग्रुप का लिंक वीडियो के इसी
वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन में मिल जाएगा
उसको जवाइन कर लीजिएगा बंटा की ग्रुप है
ठीक है समझ में आ
गया एवरीवन अंडरस्टूड गट इट क्योंकि इसमें
टाइम लगेगा क्योंकि बायपास चीजें करने के
लिए वो माइंडसेट और मेथड जीी जो है ना वो
काम करना पड़े टाइम देना पड़ेगा एंड इट
कैन बी तो जस्ट गिव इट अ ट्राई तो ट्राई
करना आप लोग ठीक है जरूरी नहीं है कि हो
जाए ये हो सकता है किस दिस इज नॉट पॉसिबल
या यह सिक्योर हो लेकिन फिर भी ट्राई करने
में क्या जाता है है ना ट्राई तो कर ही
सकते हो ना भाई इतना तो कर ही सकते हो
हमने कम से कम बहुत सारी चीजें की है अब
आप ट्राई करके देख
लीजिएगा एक ही एक ही ग्रुप है बग बाउंट
हंटर वाली जिसमें कि आप मैसेज भी कर सकते
हो ठीक है एक ग्रुप है बग बाउटी हंटर वाली
जिसमें कि आप मैसेज कर सकते हो हो राइट तो
यह काम आप कर लीजिएगा यहां पर अलग-अलग आप
हेडर्स वगैरह भी डाल के आप काम कर सकते
हैं तो एक्स फॉरवार्डेड फॉर का दोदो हेडर
भी लगा सकते हैं जैसे आप जैसे यहां पर
हमने किया था
ना ओरिजिन चलो ओरिजिन को भी आप चेंज करके
देख सकते हो यहां ओरिजिन है ना 127
हालांकि यह फिर रिक्वेस्ट एक्सेप्ट नहीं
होगा आई नो बट स्टिल स्टिल ट्राई करने में
क्या जाता है ओरिजिन कलते है यहां पे गो प
क्लिक कर देते हैं लेट्स सी 200 सक्सेस आ
रहा है यहां मेल आएगी क्या चार मेल आ गई
ये तो शायद टाइम की वजह से शायद आई होगी
बट एक बार और गो पर क्लिक करके देख लेते
हैं पांचवा मेल अगर तुरंत आ गया तो बायपास
ही है फिर लेकिन नहीं आया तो वो टाइम वाली
चीज है और कुछ नहीं है ठीक है सो नो गो पे
क्लिक करते
हैं नस नप न
न तो यहां प ओरिजिन पे तो कुछ नहीं है
यहां पे कंट्रोल जड कर देते हैं ओरिजिन जो
हमारी भाई पहले थी इनकी वही ओरिजिन लेकर आ
जाते हैं ठीक है अब यहां पे हम ऐसे भी लगा
सकते हो एक्स फॉर
वर्डेड एक्स फॉरवर्ड फॉर यहां लगा दिया
कुछ नहीं डाला इसमें इसको ब्लैंक रख दिया
नीचे में सेम चीज डाल दी सेम हेडर डाल
दिया आपने डबल एक्स फॉरवार्डेड हेडर डाल
के 120
12701 ये डाल दिया ठीक है ऐसे भी आप ट्राई
आउट कर सकते हो ट्राई करने के लिए कुछ भी
कर सकते हो वो आपकी मर्जी है और यहां पे
ओके कर दो यहां पे देख तो देखो क्या होता
है चार बार आई हुई है अगर और आ गई तो ठीक
है फोर ओनली फोर नहीं है नहीं है ठीक है
ठीक है ओनली फोर ठीक है तो ये आप ट्राई
आउट कीजिएगा गाइस दिस इज जस्ट लाइक अ
होमवर्क ठीक
है लिंक का सेंड कर दिया था ओके ललित तो
एक बार मैसेज कर लो उसी ग्रुप ग्रुप के जो
एडमिन है ना उनको मैसेज एक बार करो जो
एडमिन उसमें आपको ऐड कर दिया जाएगा ठीक
है ओके ठीक
है और कोई भी
ऐसी जो भी रूल्स है उसको फॉलो प्लेस कर
किया करना आप
लोग चलिए ठीक है गाइस देन अ आप लोग इसको
ट्राई कीजिए एज अ होमवर्क टू बायपास एंड
आपको जैसा कि मैंने आपको पहले ही बताया हर
एक चीज आपको बताई कि रेट लिमिट को बायपास
करने के अलग-अलग तरीके हैं हेडर का यूज
करके कुकी में छेड़छाड़ करके अलग-अलग तरह
के
मैल एक मैल फॉर्म रिक्वेस्ट भेज के ऐसा जो
सर्वर को लगे यू आर डिफरेंट आईपी चेंज
करके आईपी रोटेट करके एवरीथिंग यू कैन डू
चाहे ब्लैंक बाइट्स ऐड करके अलग-अलग
डिफरेंट यूजर सेशंस को यूज करके अ
सिक्योरिटी हेडर्स कोई लगे हैं तो उनको बा
डिसेबल करके या उनको बायपास करने के या
उसकी जगह पे एक इस तरह के कुछ बायपास
हेडर्स लगा के तो यू कैन जस्ट ट्राई टू
बायपास क्या बायपास द रेट लिमिट वलन
बिलिटी सिंपल सा सर्वर को ये बताना है कि
भैया मैं दूसरा यूजर हूं वही नहीं हूं
जिसको तुमने बलक ब्लॉक किया है या जिसको
तुमने बैन किया हुआ है जिसके रिक्वेस्ट को
तुमने ब्लॉक किया हुआ है तो मैं दूसरा
यूजर हूं बस रेट लिमिट में आपको यही बताना
है सामने वाले क् आई एम डिफरेंट यूजर
दैट्ची की तो आप ब्रूट फोर्स भी कर सकते
हो ओटीपी पे याद है पता है नाना आपको पता
है बब शूट से ब्रूट फोर्स कैसे करते हैं
ओटीपी पे सबको पता है ओटीपी पे ब्रूट
फोर्स कैसे करते हैं चार डिजिट का ओटीपी
हो तो या छह डिजिट का भी हो तो छह डिजिट
में तो काफी बड़ी कॉमिनेशन बन जाएगी लेकिन
चार डिजिट ओटीपी बहुत छोटी कॉमिनेशन होती
है और उसमें ट्राई आउट किया जा सकता है यू
नो सबको पता
है यूजर नेम और ओटीपी की बात नहीं कर रहा
पासवर्ड की सिर्फ ओटीपी की बात कर रहा हूं
मैं ओनली ओटी
जैसे मैं आपको बस सिंपल सा एक एग्जांपल दे
देता हूं जैसे अगर आप बब शूट आपने बब शूट
ओपन किया हुआ है ठीक है लेट्स
सपोज नहीं नहीं मैं बता देता हूं बब शट
ओपन किया है मान लो आपने ठीक है प्रॉक्सी
को बंद कर देते हैं यहां पे कोई रिक्वेस्ट
आई है आपके इंट्रूडर पे पोजीशन आपका
पोजीशन यहां पे मेंटेन होगा ठीक है यहां
पे पोजीशन होगा ओटीपी अटैक मान लो आपको
करनी है क्लियर ओटीपी कोई तो मान लो कोई
एक ओटीपी वाली फील्ड कोई भी एक फील्ड है
मान लो ये फील्ड है इसको हमने ऐड कर लिया
यहां पे पलट पे आपको बेसिकली जाना है पलट
प जब आप जाओगे ना तो यहां पे पलट टाइप में
आप क्या चूज कर लोगे आप चूज कर लोगे ब्रूट
फोर्सर ये भी चूज कर सकते हो जो भी आप
पूछे ब्रूट फोर्सर चूज कर लोगे तो
कैरेक्टर सेट यूज करना है अब मुझे तो
डिजिट खाली चाहिए ना तो कैरेक्टर सेट में
सिर्फ डिजिट रखो 0 1 टू लेके ना तक एंड
इसके बाद मिनिमम लेंथ तो मिनिमम लेंथ चार
होगी मैक्सिमम लेंथ चार होगी तो ओबवियसली
चार लेंथ की जीरो से लेकर नान तक डिजिट
यही तो ओटीपी होगी ना इसी का तो कॉमिनेशन
होगा ना इसी का कॉमिनेशन ओटीपी में जो भी
नंबर आएंगे यह बात तो मानते हो ना भाई कि
यही कॉमिनेशन
होगा चार डिजिट के ओटीपी में नंबर ही
होंगे उसकी बात कर रहा हूं ठीक है तो अब
यह करके और टोटल पेट काउंट कितने 10000
10000 जो है ना कॉमिनेशन बनेंगे यह तो
आपको ही पता होगा 10000 कॉमिनेशन लेकिन
अगर इसी को तुम छछ कर दो तो मान लो छ कर
दो और इसको छ कर दो यह
देखो 10 लाख कॉमिनेशन है समझ में आ रहा है
य 10 लाख कॉमिनेशन तो चार वाली जो ओटीपी
है यह बहुत इजी होता है अगर आप अगर कोई
रेट लिमिट नहीं है उस पर्टिकुलर प्रोग्राम
पे ओटीपी के ऊपर तो ये चार डिजिट ओटीपी
यहां स्टार्ट कर दो टैक जब तुम इस टैक को
स्टार्ट करोगे ना तो यहां जो तुम्हें अटैक
जो चलने शुरू होंगे मान लो लेट्स सपोज तो
यहां तुम्हें लेंथ से पता चलेगा जो
रिक्वेस्ट्स जो ओटीपी इनवैलिड होगी उसकी
लेंथ अलग होगी और जो सक्सेसफुल लॉगिन वाली
ओटीपी सक्सेसफुल वाली होगी जो होगा कि हां
भैया यह ओटीपी सही है बिल्कुल बकुल
बिल्कुल करेक्ट है उसकी लेंथ डिफरेंट होगी
तो लेंथ से तुम पता कर लोगे समझ में आ गया
लेंथ से पता कर लोगे 6 सा आ डिजिट की है
ओटीपी अगर तब तो खैर वो तुम सोच भी नहीं
सकते बिना मतलब का ट्राई भी नहीं करना आठ
डिजिट का अगर ओटीपी तुम डालते हो तो तुम
ये
देखो देख रहे हो ये नंबर्स लगभग 10 करोड़
10 करोड़ है
शायद ठीक है हां 10 करोड़ से ही है
ऑलमोस्ट तो यह तुम्हारा लैपटॉप की
तुम्हारे लैपटॉप की बैंड बजा देगा जब ये
तुम अटैक करोगे तो चार डिजिट का तो फिर भी
ट्राई आउट कर सकते हो बाकी का सोचना भी मत
ठीक है अगर बढ़िया प्रोसेसर या प्रोसेसिंग
पावर नहीं है तुम्हारे तो चलिए तो यह तो
आप सबको समझ में आ गया होगा सो आई होप
एवरीवन गॉट एवरीवन अ
अ गॉट टू अंडरस्टैंड रेट लिमिट रेट लिमिट
बायपास आपका कांसेप्ट क्लियर हुआ कि नहीं
पहले बता दीजिए कांसेप्ट से मुझे मतलब है
वने बिलिटी मिले ना मिले डजन मैटर यार
कांसेप्ट जब क्लियर होगा तो तुम्हें एक
दिन वलने एबिलिटी भी मिलेगी तुम्हें एक
दिन शानदार खतरनाक बाउंट भी मिलेगी
तुम्हें रिवॉर्ड भी मिलेगा ऑल ऑफ एम सब
मिलेगा तुम पहले ये बताओ थैंक यू नि
शर्क चलो बढ़िया है हां जी क्लियर है ना
बस ठीक है कोई बिजनेस लॉजिक बग देखते हैं
अभी तो अभी देखते हैं ठीक
है चलिए गाइस थैंक यू सो मच एंड वीडियो को
शेयर जरूर कीजिएगा अगर आपको अच्छा लगता
होगा क्लासेस तो अपने दोस्तों के भी जरूर
इसको बताइए इसको लोगों को बताइए ग्रुप्स
में शेयर कीजिए
whatsapp2 सब्सक्राइबर्स होने वाले हैं
20000 सब्सक्राइबर्स के लिए पहले से
धन्यवाद आप सबको अभी पहले हो जाता है फिर
धन्यवाद और करेंगे ठीक है थैंक यू सो मच
गाइस एंड मिलते हैं नेक्स्ट क्लास में और
लाइक ठोकते हुए जाना सभी बहुत-बहुत
धन्यवाद y